the winner off the tour finals and the
tour but he will aim to finish in style
against young Christoph Duda today he
will start off with the white pieces
Magnus Carlsen inside Shaq 15. what do
you expect from this match today Eureka
it's gonna be a lot of drama a lot of
action and Duda will want to win he will
want to just finish the tournament on a
high because there's nothing worse than
losing your final round match and we've
seen duda's struggle so he will come up
he will try to level up and play the big
boss you know this is what he's here for
to challenge his the closest tour rival
and they're off and we see that the game
has opened with the g-pawn moving one
square forward yep one B3 we saw
yesterday from Magnus and now it's one
G3 but she's as strange it's not quite
as strange he has transposed the
position now into an English opening and
it's what we call the symmetrical
English because look at the pawn
structure look at the pieces it's
completely symmetrical do that playing
copycat and this has quite a good
reputation for black this exact position
black is very flexible you can push a
bunch of different pawns here Black's
Knight can come out what we'll do to
choose he pushes this Pawn now white
usually here either castles or pushes
the white Pawn in the center a couple of
squares this is an alternative as well
Magnus he mentioned that word attack in
his interview with Tanya and he's going
for the attack it's only move six and
he's pushed the H Pawn forward trying to
continue pushing and if he does get the
opportunity to push Harry the H1 Square
feather forward black will seriously
have some issues to deal with and uh in
looking at the database I can see that
this was a specialty of Magnus in 2019
he used it to draw with the white pieces
against rustam kazimov and also Wesley
so so uh for some reason it's kind of
fallen out of a favor with Magnus but
it's back it's also been popular with
Anish Gary He's also played it twice
Wang Hao Michael Adams I've made this so
this this is a very established move
yeah I think I faced it myself before in
some Blitz Games in some rapid games and
it is surprisingly scary white is
keeping his King in the center and white
often keeps the king in the middle for a
lot longer essentially he's saying to
Black I'm going to keep pushing the H
Pawn you can not really Castle safely on
this King side anymore on the left side
of the board on the right side sorry
because you're going to come under Fire
there and Duda as black you're kind of
committed to a plan Black's last pawn
move pushing the pawn to E6 has created
a square for his Knight but I don't
think you can play automatic moves
anymore this is very much what Duda
likes to do actually against me once he
pushed the H Pawn forward on move three
he likes to kind of start attacking he
doesn't want to be on the back foot
reacting there's some Theory here as
well I remember some games with some
Indian youngsters sadwani won a very
instructive game here a while ago yeah
and I can tell you that there are two
very popular moves the most popular move
by far is actually to lift Black's age
porn one square forward getting ready to
meet White's Pawn Advance with a block
and another alternative is actually just
to develop the Knight but that isn't as
popular the another less popular one is
actually to pick up the edge pawn and
block the H4 Pawn immediately
so either way we're expecting Duda to at
least prepare to react to White's h-born
push
um either way it's early days in Magnus
he's got the music going yeah he's in
his comfort zone he's at the well on top
of the world right now he must be
feeling so high so happy with his
performance and confident as well these
two players have played each other 36
times in Rapid chess over the past two
seasons of The meltwater Champions chess
Tour 18 wins for Magnus against Judo you
said it many times Ivanka
Magnus has been very dominant against
Duda and I guess this is proof yeah but
I mean that's kind of traditionally been
the soundtrack you know it's always been
like Magnus playing fantastic chess you
know he's almost been able to play
anything against Duda and managed to win
but these last two matches that they've
played in the crypto Cup and the aim
chess it's been Duda who's actually won
so sure not so easy yeah and it's often
in the biggest clashes in the finals or
uh for example in the World Cup
semi-final do the Triumph there in the
rapid tie breaks um due to ended
magnus's long long unbeaten run in the
last major dudo one so it's often the
big matches where Duda saves his best
normally in the prelim stage where
Magnus just kind of rolls over Duda it's
often when Duda has nothing left to play
for that's when bad things happen so it
just depends on duda's motivation if
he's really focused if he's determined
to
beat Magnus yet again then I think he's
capable we have seen something from Duda
which is he has a tendency to tilt and
when things go really wrong they can go
catastrophically wrong and I do remember
in the Oslo Esports where Magnus just
opened with this really bizarre oh yeah
one F3 yeah and it was wasn't serious
but it really put off Duda and he just
couldn't recover and Magnus won in three
games psychological victory for Magnus
in that match yeah that's one area that
Duda needs to put serious work in uh he
got to the candidates of course he won
the World Cup but I think in order to
break into the top five top ten in the
world consistently dudo needs to just be
a bit more
stable and keep those emotions in check
and meanwhile there have been a few
moves on the board both sides are
castled so white has gone away from the
plan of pushing the H porn up but he has
forced a breakthrough in the center and
if we jump in Ivanka I'm curious this
position is brand new to me uh has it
been played before nope
answer I mean this bishop
mortally unusual never been played it's
been much more common to actually
capture the Knight on C6 or capture a
pawn in the middle of the board but
having said that the players were
already in a variation which had only
been played four times so it wasn't like
they were in mainstream Waters yeah and
this last move by Magnus it's very very
provocative he's asking Duda for example
to jump forward with his Knight to try
and attack this bishop I'm assuming here
well you can't let this bishop be
captured you'll lose the bishop pair and
your Pawn structure will be damaged so
I'm assuming Magnus wants to move his
Bishop yet again attacking the black
queen and finally we do see a purpose
for this odd looking porn move on H4 it
looks like the pawn is just doing
nothing there but it does protect the
bishop white gains time against the
queen and black center might fall apart
next move so uh that's one idea that
might not quite work for doodle right
now and you can't really release the
central tension if you take this Pawn
then after Knight takes Knight suddenly
black has some very weak pawns and these
will fall off over the next few moves
for example which Bishop can already
start getting Rudy and uh okay dude
deciding not to release the tension he's
just waiting he shuffles his Rook across
he's asking Magnus to take in the center
now because after a trade of Pawns
Black's Rook comes to life and this is a
very thematic exchange sacrifice as we
call it uh for example if white ignores
the threat of Rook takes Bishop then I
think this is automatic feduna you
capture a bishop yes you've given up a
rook in return but white structure is
eternally damaged and uh huge weaknesses
especially on the dark squares for
example the bishop can already come to
Target this pawn and this type of idea
I've seen in many games I first saw it
in a game by Gary kasparo for many many
many years ago
and uh I think this is what Duda is
aiming for but Magnus he won't be so
compliant he won't allow this to happen
yeah if Magnus allows this to happen
I would be very shocked I bet my house
sees uh he's not going to let this
happen so Magnus maybe he'll take on
this square but he definitely wouldn't
allow this second capture of the uh of
the dark Square Bishop that holds
White's position together
yeah critical moment in the game I do
like uh Doodles Rook move even though
the bar doesn't necessarily like it I
like the fact that it's it's a very
flexible move and black is signaling to
push those pawns but at the same time
hasn't committed to doing anything
concrete just yet and is now apt to
Magnus you know all the choices in his
hands you know captain of the night
capture the pawn as you indicated or is
he going to develop or something yeah
for example he could keep the tension
just Shuffle his Rook across but the
calculation is starting to happen it's
getting very Concrete in this brand new
position we're in both players on their
own it's only move 11. you do like that
remember it's a match with four rapid
games the winner in the rapid portion
takes seven hundred seven thousand five
hundred dollars and three points if it
goes to tie breaks then the winner gets
five thousand dollars on the loser two
thousand five hundred dollars
and do you think what do you think is
the most likely in this one will mine is
just keep on being dominant like over
the last few days so I could go to tie
breaks for example yeah that's the thing
because if we just look at this
tournament alone it's pretty
straightforward to say Magnus is in
charge Magnus is on a roll Magnus is
focused but I think Ivanka and I we've
both seen so many examples throughout
chess history of players achieving their
goals and then taking the foot off the
pedal and not being able to kind of play
at their best anymore it happened to me
when I got my Grandmaster title I still
had a couple of games left in that
tournament and I just couldn't I
couldn't get my head back in the game
and I've won a few tournaments with a
round to spare two rounds to spare and
it's so hard to focus so anything could
still happen Duda is the type of player
as well where yes he can go on really
bad runs but if you just give him one
chance then his confidence perks right
up and he he's a very streaky player if
he starts winning he might not stop so
the first game or two I think will be
essential to decide so it is a mental
game very much for Magnus Carlsen today
as well he is thinking now on his next
move and we couldn't finish off the
season without saying hello to someone
who has been a regular in this studio
throughout the whole season Grandmaster
Simon Williams Ginger DM hi it's so nice
to see you Simon
hi there yeah it's good to uh good to
pop in I'm a little bit late this time
on arriving but yeah yeah it's really
cool to see you all and say hello I'm
I'm afraid I'm in a little bit of a dark
room at the moment but uh I'm here in
spirit anyway so are you all doing okay
we are it's been it's been a fun week of
Chess right yeah but we have missed you
Simon very much
have you been following the tour finals
what have you thought of it Simon
is there a tournament going on all right
yeah no I I have a bit and um just just
Magnus has been incredible right
um playing playing Amazing chess and I
love their view that they've got over
the over the bridge and everything it
looks it looks fantastic the whole event
so uh quite jealous of everyone there I
agree I agree and looking back at the
whole season there's been nine
tournaments a bunch of these we've seen
a bunch of different players young ones
older ones women men what has been a
highlight for you what will you remember
from the 2022 season
I am well I think personally uh being in
the studio with you lovely people and
everyone behind the scene and um you
know I don't know if everyone watching
this stream understands like just how
many brilliant people there are over in
Norway who make it so much fun the
broadcast
um and obviously the chess I mean the
chess has been great right it's been
really exciting the format's been uh top
level and just the players we've had
some of the games uh that have been
played have been like riveting to uh to
watch and uh and also a couple of nights
out to remember as well so uh yes so
it's been a good all-round for me uh for
a personal point of view and from the
chess point of view yeah you made it a
fantastic debut in the studio Simon and
we had so much fun with you in the
studio you've been at the good night
reporting this season and you've had
many good comments and we have something
we want to show you and we have to shift
the camera to David for it to be
possible for us oh no
[Laughter]
David please you don't need to strip too
much
oh my words what is happening here oh
there we go Simon Just For You
I love it just resign your catchphrase
that is I like the T-shirt that's really
cool that's really good yeah I'm glad
you are wearing a t-shirt David I was
getting a little bit worried there for a
moment so we're you know all excited for
maybe I'm not sure
Simon that has been one of many of your
catchphrases this season just resign but
do you think it's been mostly
entertaining what the player has been up
to
be brilliant I mean uh like like say
we've had so many sort of the top
players playing and fighting
I loved about this season is uh there
hasn't been any like really quick draws
right there's been fighting chess from
start to finish
um we've had some really wacky openings
I mean Magnus went a bit mental didn't
he at one stage or some of the weird
stuff he was playing so uh all in all
it's just been great yeah really really
good fun to watch and I hope everyone
else watching has been enjoying it just
as much as uh I have commentating with
you guys in the studio
it's really been a fun year and talking
of the T-shirt just resign we of course
want to give a t-shirt to the viewers as
well so we're gonna have a quiz of today
where the t-shirt is the price and of
course we have to challenge Simon and
the Quizlet today as well tough one
we're putting you on the spot side not
again
2021 season when we did this to you
every day yeah every day it was a new
surprise
and here he goes so we're asking our
viewers at home and maybe you also Simon
can have a go to caption this picture
and there we have Ramesh and we have
Paul Prague fast asleep watching the
basketball game oh wow it looks a bit
past his bedtime doesn't it really I
mean it's like and what's that guy doing
in the background you know so that's the
other thing so
um I don't know I think Ramesh is just
saying like he he's the king here's my
kid he can get some sleep occasionally
because he's the boss he's a future
world champion let him sleep you know so
uh something on those lines but what is
the guy doing in the background he's
like getting in there as well so yeah so
impressive little photo there yeah so
where was that that was that uh um
somewhere in San Francisco right yep the
four players in San Francisco went to a
basketball game next versus Warriors and
we know Magnus really enjoyed it Denise
really enjoyed it but prag well it had
been a long day of chess
I think he's like thinking I just want
to stick to the chest right I don't you
know this this basketball is not for me
by the looks of that so uh yeah yeah
all right Simon we are finishing off uh
the season today following game one here
between Magnus Carlsen and young
Christoph Duda I'm not sure if you can
see the board but if you can I do see
that Harry has been pushed in this game
already what do you think of the
position
um looks looks pretty even at the moment
I I figure I I mean obviously I like
this H Pawn the wing Pawn being pushed
very early one of the things I love
doing uh all the time uh Black's got a
worse Pawn structure uh but they've also
got potential those Pawns in the middle
so I think it's still quite early days
um and I would say you know fairly
fairly equal at this moment in time but
I'm sure I'm sure things will heat up
quickly right so especially if that
Harry porn could just get pushing push
him push diary
fantastic time and it was so good to see
you again we wish you uh happy holidays
when that time comes and I hope to see
you again in the 2023 season
cheers everyone you have a great uh
great day so okay great night even lucky
you Simon enjoy enjoy
oh so nice to see Simon Williams again
Ginger GM he's been a regular in the
studio and we hope to see him back in
the 2023 season
you said this could get interesting
didn't really like the black poem
structure so what is happening in this
game yeah I have to completely agree
with Simon it's in the balance but it is
about to eat up the pawn structure is
very imbalanced uh here we do see black
with almost what we call hanging Pawns
in the center Black Sea and D pawns they
protect each other yes but they're on
open files they are targets potentially
for the white Rooks and black does have
an isolated Pawn the a pawn dude was
trying to push that as far down the
board as possible
unclear exactly what the purpose was
Magnus has blocked that pawn now the
black apron and he's saying okay what's
your plan next
and I guess that's the Dilemma for dudo
right now how does he improve the black
pieces they already look
pretty well placed it's hard to imagine
other than the black queen perhaps how
to improve any of them and he is at a
lost four plan he simply pushes his H
Pawn this time to block and Magnus does
take the opportunity to centralize yeah
I have to say I agree with you there
David it looks very unclear for Duda I
have to admit I I'm a bit baffled by a
magnus's sophisticated play I had
something much more direct in mind I
thought that Magnus was gonna perhaps
just explode open the center or just put
their Rooks on the open line and instead
he's put his Rook on a rather mysterious
line I mean it's just blocked it's
looking at his Queen and Bishop what
does Magnus have in store is he planning
to sidestep with the queen and go for
the week a pawn yeah that could be one
potential idea here for Magnus and Duda
also down significantly on the clock I
think Magnus is just putting his pieces
on good squares and saying okay it's up
to you to create something like you said
this could be one idea if black is too
slow White Queen sidestepping
and this is a severe weakness
I guess as well you'll write Ivanka this
is an annoying pin so you can't push the
white E Pawn anytime soon
but if you do move your queen out the
way then there might be ideas I just
don't see what black is doing for
example if black just makes a waiting
move one idea that I love for white in
these types of positions I'm not sure
it's going to happen yet but it might
happen later is to actually plant a
bishop on this square and it looks a bit
counter-intuitive it looks
anti-positional because after a trade of
Bishops white has double pawns however
white has also the perfect hiding place
for a king right now the white King on
this Square on G2 is going to be safe
forever and then you can focus your
attentions on the center I think Magnus
is just saying now for example you can
never push pawns as black because the
after a trade here the D Pawn is always
going to be weak so I think it's just
lining up he's just preparing for any
pawn breaks for black you can now win
the pawn on D5 so yeah it's this is
almost a waiting game here but on the
clocks that is not favoring Duda right
now he's a very active player okay he
doesn't move his Queen he moves his King
instead so do that very very active
player he's going to be feeling
uncomfortable he wants to do something
Dynamic he wants to attack he wants to
create threats but he's reduced to just
waiting moves I guess the only idea
behind this king move is to plant his
Bishop to attack the White Queen but is
this really going to be that effective
seems unlikely white can always just
move the queen out the way
harassing the queen and David you called
it it's like you are channeling your
inner Magnus yeah
yeah I mean this Pawn structure Ivanka
if the bishops get traded I don't think
Duda should capture right now but this
Pawn structure it comes from the karakan
defense where black has doubled f-pawns
I've played some games in the ready as
white where you get these Pawns in Blitz
Games this is just a winning position
for white essentially because you put
your King on this square and the rest of
the board you can worry about later you
just have a safe King four Pawns in
front to protect
um I also call this the bug house
structure because in a variant of Chess
Bug House chess um yeah you'll never
ever get checkmated with pawns like this
meanwhile Duda doesn't get tempted to
capture he does indeed start harassing
the White Queen he hits her and uh after
the queen stepped forward it looks like
she's trapped but Magnus found a nice
way to counter-attack he traded off a
set of pieces now and he offers the
queen trade I'm surprised that this last
couple of moves I must admit I thought
Magnus had something more aggressive in
mind but he's hoping that after the
Queens come off the board that black has
a weak Pawn Yeah and it is a weak Pawn
there's no way to defend that pawn in
fact perhaps you could jump in with the
black Bishop just defend but uh yeah it
does feel as if white now would have the
opportunity maybe to blow open the
center of the board like does have the
Bishops which makes me favor Black the
computer loves Bishops that's why the
evaluation bar has gone up in Black's
favor and these two pieces control a lot
of squares they control most of the
squares that the white Rooks want to use
actually
um so perhaps things turning in dude as
favor it does look like Magnus just
rushed a bit I was praising his play but
suddenly two three moves later the wrong
exchanges perhaps and it looks like
black could be the one with the
advantage it's still not going to be
easy for Duda to convert this but he
needs to perhaps even just give up this
pawn and Go Active with his pieces yeah
there are also targets for the black
Brooks later on remember
so yeah maybe you can start going for
them now yeah I have to admit you kind
of took the words right out of my mouth
I was going to point that out yes the
black pawn is weak but so is why it's B2
born and I do like the potential of
black staff Square Bishop it's so good
this guy can reroute itself as well to
the long diagonal and soften up the
White Queen side yeah
really surprised I must say I thought
Duda was just about to come under
pressure and Magnus perhaps because he's
won the tournament just not really
bothering to dive into a long deep think
and uh okay slightly shaking his head
there for world number one maybe
realizing that he had more promising
Alternatives earlier maybe in a little
bit of trouble here in the first game
Magnus Carlsen but he has a lot of time
on the clock right now it's Duda
thinking we just had Ginger GM on the
show he finished off with a little bit
of a toast with his uh wine or beer and
if Simon got a beer for every time this
season he has a bet on the right move he
would constantly be very tipsy
I think you'll find it I mean that yeah
maybe Simon what are we betting for
about this I think the first drink
tomorrow okay
very nice yeah Will Yan find this
important porn push
are you a drink Simon
I only drink champagne my friend oh yeah
okay I'll tell you what whatever the
first choice is okay I bet you that
Magnus you can choose if Magnus finds it
or not to get your point back okay what
is the first move okay the choice oh wow
this is difficult this is almost
impossible what's best I don't think
you'll find this oh do you wanna have a
pet then another drink another drink
okay okay good man
what
[Music]
[Laughter]
he has won a lot of bets against you
David yeah that was a very expensive
night for me and I was like buying slime
and drinks oh but he's uh yeah he's just
great at the prediction game now so you
yeah
the blunders correct
and uh well talking about the prediction
game David kind of called it he said
black would be targeting the bee pawn
and that's the move that has happened
and Magnus just realizing that he needs
to accelerate the play has uh broken the
black stronghold in the center yeah so
we've seen a trade of Pawns in the
center we might see a trade of the light
squared Bishops but it's all about
whether black can take advantage now
Black's Rook can capture on B2 anytime
he wants black's Bishop also has lots of
targets look at all the white pawns
they're on dark squares what does black
half darts go a bishop so to me despite
the evaluation bar being in the middle
it does feel like black is the only one
who can play for Advantage but maybe
just with his last couple of moves uh
it's too late maybe just all the pieces
are flying off the board it does look
like Magnus has found a way to liquify
liquidate the position
and force the draw oh will we see a draw
in this game one
it is Duda thinking now we're gonna go
to San Francisco it is the final day of
the tour finals with four players and
Tanya onsite in San Francisco how are
you guys doing on this final day Tanya
uh we're having so much fun here Kaya
and even though we do have a winner of
the tournament I have to say the
matchups today I just love them some
really epic fights here Magnus is facing
his Nemesis Duda we've got an all Indian
clash with Prague against Arjun so a big
day of Chess and to enjoy all of that we
do have a young chess fan here with us
it is Seb he is a local talent here from
the Bay Area Sam welcome to the show are
you enjoying yourselves yes I'm enjoying
uh being here very much it's a great
experience to see the players in action
and
meet them I have to ask you when did you
start playing chess uh I started playing
chess when I was five years old but I
didn't really play all I did was know
how to move the pieces and I actually
basically started playing chess for real
tournaments when I was 10 years old and
one covet hit and from there we were at
the Mechanics Institute earlier and you
were there as well you got a chance to
hang out with Prague Anish and Wesley
how was that for you uh it was great you
know getting to know them and seeing
them in real life not just online
and uh getting to another personality
meeting them showing off and telling
stories I guess did you have a fun chat
with them yeah I showed them my board uh
oh my
autographs and they were very intrigued
by it so cool and you're here today are
you looking forward to meeting Magnus
it's the one that I've left out of all
four uh I'm very excited especially
because he is the King of Chess uh good
at glitch bullet rapid classical
now I remember back at The Institute you
mentioned that you're rooting for Wesley
you must be happy to see that he's won
all his four matches
I'm very happy that he had a great
comeback especially I think this cost
was from the global Chess Championship
even though he lost the first two games
he can't cut came back and is doing
better I have to ask you who is there so
many great players here in the US who is
your personal favorite
my favorite chess player in the US
probably Hikaru Nakamura because I love
playing Blitz and he's like the Blitz
the best Blitz player and I also like
Wesley so his personality and his
kindness yeah he's super kind but do you
think Hikaru is the strongest when it
comes to speeches
uh yes I feel like he's probably gonna
win the speed test Championship coming
up tomorrow I'm pretty sure and yeah I
wish him good luck oh and akaya there is
a little story here with Sab and Hikaru
this was at the candidates tell us about
this it's a nice score sheet so this was
I was playing in the chess kid
candidates during the candidates that
happened in the morning so we finished
in the morning and after I finished in
the morning
the feta head Arbiter of the tournament
Anastasia she went and gave me the score
sheet of Hikaru ding Lyon the first game
um I I was so happy and I went down
since the current ding finished and I
got them both to sign the autographs on
each
and I think this is hikaru's handwriting
I'm not sure though
wow so the top chess players continue to
inspire the young Generations lots of
moves happening lots of inspiring moves
happening on the chessboard right now
back to you guys in the studio oh thank
you Sebastian and Tanya how how cool is
that score sheet that could actually be
the next World Champion signing that
dingley Wren who will pay on the
pubniacci next year for the world
championship title
very cool very cool do you guys keep
your score sheets I keep all of them I
don't think I've ever been to squishy
and I know your bank is different though
Uganda doesn't keep them and if we Bank
her loses she rips them up
because it's like all that that bad
karma gone and uh yeah but uh I do kind
of do keep memorabilia I do like to keep
little tokens and you take the pieces
and stuff
not advocating that at all no no no just
bringing the whole board I'll take this
home that's a memory
that's just theft yeah
and then we see the king escape from the
king side and move towards the center
and whilst players are thinking I do
want to share with you one very nice
tweet from claritza who tells us the
bigger the pout the better the game and
he's done a drawing of our favorites
gold medalist commentator and she's got
your autograph there as well David shout
out to Marissa yeah I think we met
briefly in Chennai Marissa was playing
as well in the Olympiad and yeah I'm
honored thank you
uh yeah I think that picture was based
on one of the games that I played there
as well I can see with the England
jacket that's right yeah the England
Blazer that we're very proud of
am I wearing the same shirt here that I
was there that's embarrassing
the pink one yeah oh that's very cool
thank you Maritza a talented artist
drawing a talented chess player it's
very nice yeah and uh in the meantime
the pawns have moved up the board but
I'm fully expecting the white Rook just
to move two squares to get behind
Black's past sea porn and oh he gives a
check first yeah that shows that Magnus
is playing for the win he really
shouldn't get too carried away he should
try and play the safe uh over the next
few moves because Black's rook and
Bishop do actually combine better than
White's Rook at night but uh yeah it
should still be within the drawing
margins here I did have the opportunity
to force the drawers you mentioned
Ivanka if you go for Black Sea porn in
time yes you lose your a pawn as white
but those two pawns on the left side
will disappear it's completely
symmetrical and the other flank dead
draw but suddenly where's White's night
going is Magnus Really Gonna Get greedy
and try and grab some of those black
Pawns on the right side because then
you're forgetting about the Black Sea
Pawn
and look at this suddenly a check
White's night is getting kicked away
the black porn might be motoring forward
it's Magnus on tilt he's got 10 minutes
he hasn't used any time at all uh he's
just
feels to me as if he's already risking
significantly here he needs to pull that
handbrake and say okay let's find a draw
now
because Black's pieces are just looking
fantastic Black's King as well it's
valuable piece in these types of end
games it can Shepherd pawns forward
white tonight retreating I just feel
that Magnus is being complacent he feels
like he can play almost anything he
likes and it will still be a draw but
he's taking such big risks here because
as you say Black's pieces are swarming
forward and you've got to always
remember when it comes to the end game
is the quality of the pawns not the
quantity so in terms of quality it just
depends on like how far Advanced they
are up board whether they can promote
easily and there we see Duda just
attacking the night tonight will have to
move or be defended yep I'm expecting
maybe the king to retreat and defend
this but
yeah where are you going with your
Knights you have to run to some very
awkward squares if you want to find
safety
maybe Magnus was just having one eye on
the clock he sees that dude is down at
one minute and he thought okay I'm gonna
take some calculated risks some measured
risks but one minute for a player like
dude it's still a lot of time
so it is time to backtrack to backpedal
and try to stay safe I advocate just
defending that night now with the white
king
think it's still okay because White's
Pawn White's A6 Pawn will cause a
distraction at some point where it's
Rook will be able to slow behind
attacking that black C Pawn maybe giving
some checks later
so there's enough defensive resources
but suddenly the tightrope
is narrowing of a very small path to
hold the draw with white okay I reckon
that Magnus will not defend that night I
think he'll move it I no I think he's
going to move his Rook to the eighth row
okay that would be very sneaky Ivanka so
this position should be a draw but
there's always tricks involved and
Magnus could set a little trap here just
by ignoring the threat on this Knight
this is very pretty just stepping
forward with the white rook and now if
the Knight is captured then white would
win a check and a skewer the King has to
run out the way and next move the black
Rook would drop and white will make a
new Queen so it's never too late to set
traps that would also be very
interesting the reason you plant The
Rook forward one square is because right
now yes the Knight is attacked but you
can't come back and check because
Black's Bishop covers that square so you
just threatened to jump to a light
square and uh yeah I guess here just to
illustrate why we think this will be a
draw eventually Black's Pawn at some
point will start to push and maybe white
has better here even but just as an
example the white record slide behind
this Pawn will disappear this Pawn will
disappear and yeah the king-size
structure here on the right side no way
to make a head Headroom into that one so
dead draw okay
there is now 55 minutes left to cast
your vote for the best game of the
Champions chess tour season 2022 only 55
more minutes so the way to do it is you
head to chest24.com tour if you scroll
just a little bit down you will find the
vote there are nine games you can vote
for you'll find the link to the chest 24
site where you can check the games
there's also videos for each of the
games Magnus is nominated for a few of
them Duda is also nominated in a few of
them there is that big big mama Dr of uh
game when he beat anishikiri
there are nine different games and you
have now 55 minutes to cast your vote
this is one of the bonus prices this
season so the winner is the two players
in that game will get a big bunch of uh
that uh bonus price fund which is over
80 000 big right now
nine is nominated for quite a few of
them actually I think there's two
Carlson Duda games that you can vote for
oh yeah I mean these two they've had
some real ding dong battles throughout
the year and okay with this last move
Magnus didn't go for the draw we saw the
white king poke its head out black
checked the king back and the position
repeat itself once Magnus is playing on
he's attacking this black Bishop but I'm
wondering what happens here if for
example black tries to keep things
simple and just takes the White Knight
does white have anything better than
taking the black Bishop then we would
see a draw most likely
still Ivanka yeah I mean I would
actually be tempted to try to play for
more you know Magnus is taking risks why
can't black do the same I would be
tempted just to retreat the bishop one
square forward
C5 yeah back to C5 and kind of again
asked the question or I could uh if I
was feeling super confident actually I
might even put the bishop on the D2
Square because after all the bishop on
D2 will got the ace sorry c one square
that's really ambitious and dude is
ticking down to 30 seconds
if he moves his Bishop we will see a lot
of twists and turns ahead I think if he
wants to play it safe if he wants to
commit to the draw now Duda he'll just
take the White Knight with blacks Rook
but he's not got that much time he looks
away maybe in a bit of frustration there
Duda but uh now we will see the game
steer towards the draw the bishop
disappears Black's Rook has got to go
after that white a pawn before it's too
late
put it back where it came from that Rook
and the game is
automatically almost a draw there's no
way to keep these two pawns on the board
and uh before the game quickly Fizzles
out we do have a caption this
competition where you can answer using
the hashtag chess Champs and there The
Rook does go behind the pawn the game is
gonna fizzle out and any second now
they'll find a way to repeat the moves
okay there we go check the king and Rook
do a little dance the position repeats
itself and it has been a hardcore game
but it is a draw
first game in their match a draw Magnus
Carlsen taking a big sip of the liquid
death the nice water sparkling water
that they are drinking in Shack 15 he
will have now 22 minutes Magnus crossing
the library for game two where he will
have the black pieces and we're gonna go
to San Francisco to see if we can get a
reaction from Magnus
Magnus you were really up on the clock
but the end game was still very tricky
were you ever worried yeah I mean I
missed speech page six completely which
is uh you know uh not ideal when his
last move skh7
uh and then yeah I mean I thought before
that session was about equal maybe I was
slightly worse but after that I thought
it was much worse uh but but
um yeah
um fortunately I managed to liquidate
pretty quickly into something that was
drawn and then
I had the slight chances if any
especially because of the time but um
there was nothing uh you played this new
interesting idea with Bishop E3 were you
uh did it work to Perfection considering
how much he burnt the clock not really I
mean I I remember I had this position
against qasim and the um in 2019 Isle of
Man and I burned a lot of time there as
well and I played cd5 which is
um which is a decent move but he should
go Ed there so
I was thinking during the game like uh
today like um I don't didn't remember
why Bishop E3 was was not good and then
he played rookie eight and I was like oh
yeah that's why uh so I mean the
position just is nothing for white
regardless of what you do that's funny
because rustom actually mentioned that
after your game against him in the
analysis you mentioned rookie 8 as a
problem yeah I mean I I remember
remember it right after he played the
move all right well good luck for the
second game thanks
20 minutes until game two game one is
going on for young Prague today he is
playing his fellow Indian and fellow
teenager Arjun aragaisi it's been a
tough few days now for Prague but uh
Arjun has won three matches in a row
but in this first game together between
those two the bar is very much over to
bright side yeah yeah it looks like a
Master Class by Prague I've been playing
through the game he's steered this one
towards an advantage and he's also won a
pawn in the process if you do a quick
count black is one Pawn up but it's
about to become two because Black's
Knight is going to LEAP back and win
either the G4 Pawn or the E4 Pawn white
can't hold everything together also note
how the white king is cut off Black's
Rook does a great job on the D file of
stopping the white king from shifting
sides and therefore aragaisies pretty
much forced to just push pawns this Pawn
is not going anywhere
Prague will just at the right moment
capture another Pawn with his Knight and
start running with his extra material it
looks very straightforward Black's King
can start advancing down the board to G5
towards those white Pawns
yeah it looks quite straightforward at
this point yeah Ivanka looks totally
winning if you ask me and the King does
take a step forward I mean they can even
step forward again but I think I would
just simply just capture the pawn it's
up for grabs and there's only so long I
can resist temptation yep I mean what
can be more simple than just taking a
porn a free porn no consequences no
compensation for white
I'm not really sure what arjun's doing I
guess he just can't find a plan and he's
got less than one minute on the clock so
he's just pushing trying to distract any
scary and not anishkiri pregnant sorry
and uh okay that pawn does drop so two
Pawn Advantage also remember we've seen
this yesterday we've seen it several
times throughout the tour each pawns are
the best against Knights White's Knight
will struggle to stop that black h-born
from running and you can start pushing
it now All Black's King can come even
closer towards the center plenty of
winning moves there we go there's
another weak port and of course white
does have an isolated Pawn in the center
it's about to be a three-point advantage
and we might see Eric icy resign any
moment two points is already too many
but three that's the Tipping Point it
definitely is I mean a fair play to Eric
I see he is fighting hard you know he's
trying to generate some counter play by
targeting Black's pawns on the left but
fortunately it's just Mission Impossible
and he's taken some time out to improve
his King
pawns get traded off
and like you say David the age Pawn will
come running yeah I mean you can just
capture in the center as well Black's
King can get greedy I think can't see
any downside there you just have to
calculate perhaps a couple of checks but
price still has one minute he's so good
in these scenarios and he does abandon
Black's H porn but he's going after the
key e-born now and Black's Knight is
going to do the grabbing
yeah just textbook end game technique
I mean you mentioned Eric ice he's
fighting hard but Prague is not allowing
him to fight effectively that's the key
every guys he's trying his best to
create counterplay there we go the H
Pawn does disappear but blacks Nike can
now just jump back win a second Pawn
game over White's night is too far from
the action now
white light is almost trapped on the
edge of the wood it is actually I mean
uh for starters you would calculate
Knight takes pawn and like you say can
you trap that night put your Rook on the
G line
it's gone yeah why it's night is almost
uh yeah it's almost falling off the
board so every guy see lifts his Rook up
black has two connected passports any
exchange here any nitrate or any Rook
trade would end uh the game I don't
think Eric Garcia would continue there
but why not push pawns first and
foremost
hospitals are there to be pushed and
this poor now is attacked by White
spaces but it can be defended by Black's
Knight
and did you do well and then it will be
the e-pawn that comes marching here it
comes and all the while whites
what has nothing to do I mean white just
has to sit there and wait and I'm fully
expecting that Eric Garcia would just
throw in the towel yeah he'll raise that
white flag he's going to resign I think
Eric I see there's simply nothing else
to do practice showed he knows how to
win this one he's protected everything
and it's the e-born is it the time
[Applause]
and this incidentally is the t-shirt
that you guys can wear at home if you
answer our caption this competition
that is a cool t-shirt it's gonna happen
Ivanka I think black just needs to play
one more move he's going to retreat his
Rook pin that white knight and White's
gonna resign
ah where's Simon when you need him yeah
okay it's it's only a match it's on the
edge
okay no oh he doesn't go for the PIN but
it's quite brutal I mean going for the a
pawn strong enough the E Pawn is also
going to start advancing are we gonna
see it
a few squares away now
the White Knight Retreats attacking
Black's Rook but Prague doesn't need a
rook he's simply going to keep pushing
and now he's gonna block the white Rooks
connection with that black pawn there we
go with the Knight blockades black is
about to make a new Queen and he's going
to resign her a guy see we do have a
result
wow Prague takes the first point and
this all Indian battle with a great game
having the black pieces so he rushes off
Frank
the last player in the San Francisco
Arena to finish the first round of games
on this final day in the tour finals I
hope we get a reaction after that
beautiful win
Prague you've taken the lead in this
match to us it looked like Flawless
technique are you happy with your end
gameplay yeah I think it was a good game
overall maybe I was slightly worse in
the opening but um after I got this D4
and Knight C6 I think black should be
completely fine and I think somewhere
there I misplayed and uh got to I think
this B4 was just a bad news like I got
93 and just one upon and yeah it was
smooth game after that uh G6 was the
move that impressed us all at the end
game do you feel that was the moment uh
The crucial decisive moment yeah I
actually had foreseen it earlier itself
so it was kind of easy to find for me
there because otherwise my my knight is
kind of stuck there uh because I can't
take 9g for it at all because there is
Rook G3 and um is threatening some Rook
E2 or something like that and my knight
is stuck so I have to find G6 well you
did all the best for the next one thank
you
fantastic start to the final day for
Prague we came in very late in the game
but how did he win it David so there
were some key moments I might just need
a second to pull it off uh this was the
key moment uh where Prague clinched it
he mentioned that he did win a pawn
thanks to an earlier slip from Eric icy
but you can't get too hasty in any end
game uh here Prague calmly pushed his G
Pawn forward and we'll show why that was
so good in a moment if he'd been greedy
however and captured first with the
Black Knight this week porn then white
does obtain serious counterplay suddenly
the white Rook shifts and uh after the
Black Knight moves one of Black's pawns
drops a key pawn and suddenly Black's
position collapses the black king now in
some serious danger so he avoided that
Pitfall prag he simply pushed his Pawn
forward and this posed an impossible
problem to the White Knight The White
Knight is the only good piece for Eric
icy If It Moves now and captures a pawn
for example it gets trapped on the edge
of the board and instead Eric icy had to
Simply capture this aloud Black's King
to get active the white porn pushed
forward King came to G5 and only now did
Prague start going after the white pawns
really calm really patient strategy and
as we saw later on those black pawns on
the king side did decide the game
[Music]
great start for a young Prague on the
final day of the tour finals years up by
one point in his final match here
against fellow Indian Arjun Eric Garcia
and Indian teenagers they have made a
big mark on the tour this season Arjun
he made it all the way to the final in
the Julius bear generation cup
wins
that's a killer I think he might resign
he's been on fire and here winning
against one of the Legends in chess you
see a really nice finish here after Rook
takes porn
at night it's true
and runs through and wins what a start
for our generic icy here it is we have a
teenager in the final and the Julia's
very generation cup he knocks out Liam
one of the top players this season on
the tour
it has been a season full of historical
moments made by Chester teenagers
Geniuses at just 15 16 17 years old and
one of them is only 13 years old I'll be
Manu Mishra the first day of the air
things Masters is probably a day that
young chess player will never forget
Mishra is about to win yeah it's almost
guaranteed at this point direct down to
two seconds as well he needs to move
it's just a cleaning up job now for
Mishra he's been ruthless right now over
the board she finish nice nice kind of
tactic there no chance now of Eric
saving this game no plan simply and look
at that he Bobs his head he's trading
queens and he wins the game it looks
like he could uh win another one he
should win this one I think if he had 30
minutes on his cook it would be a
guarantee but it's all about the clock
and also that white king there's gonna
be traps there's gonna be threats
against it so we're going to see
Checkmate on the board to see it I
Mishra celebrates I can't make next
moves like King trapped wow what an
impressive performance by 13 year old
Abby Monument not only did he win his
game against Eric Hansen here he is also
winning against one of the top 10
players in the world
[Music]
what a big moment for Mishra at only 13
years old he's also the youngest Grand
Master in history and teenagers Ivanka
they've been a huge Factor this season
on the tour how fun has it been
just beat these top players yeah and the
great thing about them is that they play
Fighting Chess you don't see any quick
draws you see them just take their
chances against the top players and
they've scored a lot of upsets and it
just goes to show what happens when you
give these young players the platform to
play against the world's best what is
the advantage David of being a chess
player in your teens what are you better
off at often there's a few things you're
very optimistic
um when you're young you don't have any
fear you're not afraid to step forward
attack often when players play Magnus
they're fearful but the youngsters know
they want to take down the king also you
have a lot of energy you're happy to
snuggle down play these long games and
you don't have too many distractions
some of the older players in the
tournament they have families for
example managerov he has kids he's got
other distractions other things to worry
about Anish giri has a family too but
the youngsters no it's just chess they
can study as much as they can they've
also all got great coaches around them
credit to the coaches of the players who
played on the tour this season
they've got this great support network
and uh yeah all of those factors
combined means that they can fight
against anyone even more experienced
Rivals yeah and without uh like players
like Wesley so as a regular this season
on the tour do you think the teenagers
have been a big motivation for Magnus
this season definitely Magnus loves to
fight we saw moments last season when he
was getting frustrated his players were
just trying to kind of force draws
against him he wasn't able to get in the
flow occasionally but the the youngsters
they forced him to hit another level
Magnus they're taking the fight to him
you see how happy Magnus is even when
Prague beats him he's saying oh I
appreciate that I'm out of my comfort
zone they're pushing me they're forcing
me to learn to adapt and yeah I think
all of the more experienced players
there embracing the challenge as well
yeah I guess safe to say about the
future is very bright for chess yeah
definitely and I have to say I do
remember in one tournament I think it
was the aim chess wrap rapid where
Magnus struggled against the teenagers
he'd be everyone but couldn't beat the
kids
now where the age though Khan's
experience and you would maybe think
that online rapid chess is mostly for
the youngsters but in the Julius bear
generation cup one of the biggest
Legends of Chess basketball gave us
great entertainment
I could just look at Chucky just put the
video on a full screen bit you know
classical music in the back no no I mean
look at it it's it's such a interesting
character to look at isn't it we talk
about controlling the center in chess
look at what white has done with his uh
formation there it's just kind of
everything protected everything
controlled got seven seven what's he
doing
so relaxed
horn just uh opening up the position
oh I think the Tilt has started now the
black queen can just go and take the
white light squared Bishop oh no look at
his face oh no he's just a rook down now
it just looks beautiful beautiful for
white
wow
beautiful back that wins the game there
we go he takes the win of antrik
a kill us I think he might resign
because really I'm ready I think he
might be losing that night actually as
well I mean the Knight has nowhere I
can't see how you saved that night it's
been on fire and here winning against
one of the Legends in chess verse
levancic what a game in only 25 moves
and uh it is captured wow he lets the
queen appear on the board but now
it feels like he's winning they're so
loose these pieces she feels like she'd
have a force twin head even you know
what to move by Iranian
and he's saying take the Rook because
the mic is gonna jump to the D6 square
and Fork everything and now it just
looks like it's winning for white what
what happened this night check is going
to dislodge the black king what is going
to make a new Queen game over if vantrik
shakes his head
poor Chucky hands now and he does click
that resign button
he was knocked out in the prelims but
that was huge entertainment we've had
Legends we've had teenagers and we also
had three women participating this
season on the meltwater Champions chest
or one of them women's world champion
Jew and Jun made a great performance and
almost qualified for The Knockout stage
[Music]
she's winning this is a huge blunder by
way he he's missed a really important
trick
okay the Queens are off and uh now it's
going to be very very difficult for
weight year one last threat for white
white was threatening to go up to the
top of the board with this rook and
check but no more checks has we given up
there we go
wow what a performance today by Juwan
Jun she beats her fellow Chinese player
yeah and one of the highest star rated
players in the world that was a
fantastic performance by Juan Jin and
for you Ivanka as the female chess
player yourself always have been like to
see the women compete on the tour this
season it's been fantastic to have that
visibility so to see the women just play
the best players in the world to see
them perform with confidence and I have
to say I really have a soft spot for
that particular moment when Jew engine
she almost qualified and she came so
close and I remember she it was almost
miraculous recovery at the end but uh
it's just inspiring this is the great
thing when you see women play and young
girls or anyone watching they'll go okay
I can aspire to be that person and
that's a very important moment yeah who
could we maybe see on the 2023 season of
the tour David who what women are up
there and fighting right now I mean you
and June women's world champion we've
seen in the candidates there are plenty
of strong players Lee Ting Jay there's
the musee truck sisters there's Humpty
married as I mean it's almost countless
there's a lot of young girls coming up
right Ivanka as well who in future years
they will be challenging not just in uh
for those titles but also in these types
of events it will be great to see them
given the opportunity as you mentioned
yeah yeah we we talked about future for
chess in general but what do you say
about future for women in chassis wanker
yeah it's an important subject actually
and the way that you can just improve
women's chess is again just improve the
visibility just have women playing have
women commentating have women Arbiters
have women all levels of the board all
over all levels and just support their
Ventures and we're seeing it more and
more you know there's now women
exclusive tournaments running alongside
like the Tata steel Invitational and
it's clear it's so great to see women
just competing with the world's best
because they more the more that they
compete at that level the better they
will become there's no doubt about that
yeah unfortunately no women here in the
tour final most of the World Watcher
Champions chess tour but I have a
feeling if not next year in a few years
we will see a woman chess player fight
for the title as well here are the
results from the first set of games on
the final day here in the tour finals a
draw between Wesley son and nishikiri
both playing in San Francisco
the bar was over to his side for big
parts of the game eventually losing that
game to Liam there did you check that
out David I did there was a huge
turnaround just before the end chakra
went from winning to losing in just one
move perhaps that's tiredness playing in
the world team championship earlier
today but either way yeah I'm showing
his resourcefulness yeah
it was a draw between Magnus Carl's
Nadia and Christoph Duda but a big win
for Prague again sergeant aragaisy in
that first game and Prague will have the
white pieces in game two we're gonna
follow that battle between the two young
Indians
Frank has been a regular this season on
the tour
Arjun has been playing quite a bit in
the last few tournaments
but not too many times have they faced
each other one win for Prague one draw
and that win came in the previous game
yeah I'm surprised they haven't faced
each other so often on the tour it feels
like these two are regular fixtures now
at the top of Rapid chests at the top of
World Chess even so this is the start of
a budding rivalry and Eric Garcia will
not want to lie down he will want to
strike back immediately
crack with the white pieces will he be
able to take an even more more
commanding lead
17 years old
10 years old and old and played on the
on the first team in the chess Olympiad
Prague played on the second team but the
second team actually did better and
Prague did fantastic on board three he
took the bronze medal David took the
gold medal on board the three was that
prestigious do you think David for the
Indian's second team to actually beat
the first team yeah I think it was just
a landmark moment where it was a coming
of the new generation a changing of the
god I think maybe the biggest blunder
that the second team made was not
including Eric icy it could have been
all teenagers in the second team and I
think he might have been the missing
ingredient that would have given them
the gold medals both of these guys
actually got medals individual medals as
well on board three oh that's true so uh
Eric icy and uh Prague Eric he took the
silver guys he took the silver three yes
so right now in this image we have the
medalists from the chess Olympiad on
board three not now because I'm in here
but if you put David on gold medal is
David silver medalist Arjun and bronze
medalist Prague
yeah but these two I mean what
superstars they are they were so nice to
me as well uh up there when we were on
the podium uh we had a chat every guys
he was congratulating me and uh yeah
Prague as well shared a Podium with his
sister both him and his sister won
bronze medals uh meanwhile a lot of
moose in this one it was the slav
defense Rock Solid for black but you can
see how well they know each other they
both predicted up to this point move 13
instantly played Ivanka and Arjun was in
fact repeating an opening that he'd
played against
yesterday's opponent which has
completely slipped my mind Arjun Arjun
yeah he beat a niche didn't he that's
true
I will know he beat the Liam Liam yes
it's been a long season
but sometimes it happens like yeah
there's always one player that I forget
I was trying to remember someone I was
like who is it and I was like Shaq of
course
here is Liam okay and I hear the light
squared Bishop develops and uh they're
in new territory now
so here there's not too many imbalances
in the position it's mainly just that
classic uh kind of battle between the
bishop pair and Black's minor pieces
white has that Bishop pair the center is
blocked very blocked right now so white
Bishops don't look too impressive the
other imbalance is black having the
semi-open H file due to those double
pawns now that black has on the g-file
black's Rook is open so if you're Arjun
okay if you pushes the pawn uh if you're
black here you don't really want to rush
to Castle the king because maybe Black's
Rook is actually more active where it
currently stands than it would be
towards the center so flax King could
just inch its own way towards safety
behind that pawn Mass on the right side
without moving his Rook away off that H
file meanwhile Prague doesn't really
want to Castle as white either because
then the black Rook is primed to attack
and I've got to say I love these types
of positions for black in general just
because you're so solid and actually
it's up to White the there's a lot of
pressure on white to find a plan which
side do you go with your king do you
push Pawns in the center with black you
can just kind of sit and uh yeah no
weaknesses that's that's very very true
I actually played this position for both
white and black and I have to say I have
a slight preference for the white
position because I feel that the white
king is that touch more safe to save
that um for instance one of the plans
that I've done in the past which perhaps
isn't so attractive now is actually to
Castle the king all the way over to the
left and the whole idea with that is
like as soon as black gets ready to
commit the King which they will do at
some stage then the H pull will just go
zooming up the board and you have a
ready-made attack now the reason why I'm
not 100 confident with casting the king
this particular way is because look at
Black's pieces they're primed for that
uh King run and they get getting ready
to see space on the left side yeah so we
could see a battle of black pushing
pawns on this flank white pushing pawns
maybe in the center but also on the
other
on the other flank yeah it's a really
kind of tense position which could well
explode and become very chaotic in the
course of two or three moves and it's a
bit of a standoff right now on either
side wanting to commit their King and
yeah I definitely don't think we'll see
Prague Castle this move unless he's got
a concrete idea up his sleeve more
likely white will prepare white will
start getting ready at some point just
to push forward and gain space I don't
think you can kind of rush to do this
there are tactics in the air for example
after a pawn trade here black does have
tactics immediately he does Castle
actually but he black here would have a
nice tactic hitting the queen hitting
the bishop and if the Knight is captured
Black's Queen would pounce White's
pieces are very loose and this would
have been great for black but meanwhile
he does actually uh rather than push his
Pawn in the foot forward in the center
he does commit his King he does Castle
into the line of fire apparently Ivanka
you look uh confused I am very confused
because white doesn't do this white
generally actually either goes to the
left with the king or actually steps to
the F2 Square you rarely put your king
in this particular position because like
you've indicated the black Rook is open
it's primed to start an attack yeah
serious attacking ideas against this
white king I must confess I did
something similar to this myself at the
Olympiad like you said I didn't Castle
but I pushed my king in this direction
and the whole idea was to put the King
on this Square just to keep it on a
light Square black has no light Square
Bishop so it's very hard to attack this
piece once it reaches G2 but you're
right Ivanka it's very surprising to see
Prague a bit so early uh it's equally
surprising I've got to be honest here
that arigosi after seeing the white King
on the king side he just plays on the
other flag he pushes his people and it's
as if he was expecting the white king to
go the other way but it just feels
inconsistent White Castle's King side so
you play on The Queen side you should be
uh maybe switching attention here
towards the white king side let's yeah
we'll see what both players have in
store I think it's up to Prague now to
consolidate his King's position just to
build some type of Fortress around it
I'm very much expecting him to push
forward over the next couple of moves
just because you don't want to allow
black to move his between out with gain
of tempo or perhaps even the bishop to
gain time you want to keep the square
safe as long as possible as quickly as
possible as well so I would expect this
move other candidates come into mind
just centralizing the white Rooks maybe
stepping back with the white knight into
the center
lots of options here yep
is uh thinking he's up by one point in
his match against Arjun erag icy see he
was in a great mood in the interview
with Tanya after that first game and it
seems Tanya everyone is just very happy
in San Francisco today
absolutely Kyle as are we well you got
such amazing chess action going on and
some incredible guests what's not to
love and we've got a very special one
here with us it is hido Ambience he is
from the Netherlands he is a Nobel Prize
winner in economics and a chess player
uh you know it's such a pleasure to have
you here with us thanks very much
I want to stop by just asking you
because you're here from the Netherlands
are you rooting for Anish Guru is he
your favorite chest yes yes I am rooting
for him and I'm sorry hasn't done
particularly well this tournament but
he's done great in the past and
hopefully he'll do better again in the
future do you follow the events and have
you been following the tour I've been
following the tour I still try to follow
the the main tournaments especially some
in the Netherlands of course they have
very regularly top tournaments there
um hero tell us you are a Nobel Prize
winner in economic studies I want to ask
you as a chess player what are the
similarities how has chess helped you in
your journey
but so when I was in when I was young
when I was in high school I played a lot
of Chess and I think the the main thing
where it really helped me is that it
really kind of taught me how to focus in
those days we're still playing kind of
with classical controls and so we would
play four or five hour games and it was
just really you know important you kind
of just shout out the rest of the world
you would just focus on one thing for
four or five hours and that's still
really important in the work I do now I
kind of just at times I need to think
really hard and really be able to kind
of just really focus and that's that's
where the the chess experience was just
particularly uh useful so throughout
your economics career has just played a
big role I said I've not played that
much kind of since I started going to
college but I sort of kept following the
tournaments kept following the World
Chess uh championships as so now it's
great to be able to attend some of the
tournaments in person again so that's
been really fun and you mentioned that
uh you were also a professor along with
Ken rogoff who's also a very famous
economist as well as a chess player uh
tell us about that experience and your
interaction with him yeah sure yeah so
when I was on the faculty at uh at
Harvard uh cambroga was also in the
economics Department there it's
obviously he's a very good chess player
so we would talk occasionally he would
tell me about some of the meetings he'd
had with Bobby Fisher and so we we and
we talk about some of the things going
on in the Chess World now as it was just
really fun having him as a as a
colleague
awesome and are you enjoying your time
here watching the players in action at
the meltwater Champions Chester yeah
that's been a lot of fun it's been a
long time since I've actually visited a
tournament in uh in person but I I did
that kind of Fairly regularly when I was
in uh in high school and just really
interesting to see it again now and and
see how this uh how the tournament is
going thank you so much for joining us
that we have a chess and economics a
perfect fit back to you guys in the
studio
wow we're almost getting a little star
struck here that is uh huge and how cool
to have him in San Francisco a fan of
both mathematics and chess we do have a
few moves on the board what's happening
here yep just a couple of moves since we
last visited this position essentially
white is regrouping his pieces uh Prague
we did see him Retreat his night the
White Knight was about to maybe get hit
by some black porn so some preemptive
Retreats there and white Rook now
centralized so it does look like White's
pieces are huddled in the center but if
Brad gets the opportunity to step
forward the white eporn his position his
pieces especially will be given a lot
more life and Arjun meanwhile has used
his last couple of moves to gain space
and now Black's Knight is about to jump
into the white half Black's night might
well just land on the C4 square and
it will cause some nuisance there Ivanka
what do you think of these recent
developments
it's uh still very cagey position I'm
not really sure who's better and I have
to be honest with you my you know I do
quite like the black side but then again
I can see the potential as you've
highlighted for white you know if just
some maneuvering and white will have the
potential to expand in the center and
that will be very uncomfortable for
black so as far as I can see
I would say Even Stevens I'm not going
to commit to a decision yeah both sides
have reason to be happy so some
positions we say are equal that means
chances are Level it's uh it's hard to
kind of mess with the equilibrium but
this one it could go either way it's
just about who's more creative who's
more tenacious perhaps when they come
under pressure it's first White who had
to react to a threat white doesn't want
to partner with his Bishop here if if
that black knight had been able to trade
itself off for one of White's Bishops
then only black could be better so
Prague takes a step back preserving his
Bishops and if he gets one more move
Prague he will step forward push that
white Pawn to E4 and perhaps the
momentum will change so yeah again it's
up to Eric icy he's got more time how
can he continue the threats continue
before white gets organized he needs to
win a game after losing the first one
and uh in that interview with Tanya we
did see someone who's received the Nobel
Prize for economics science and it
reminded me I just have to tell you guys
about John Nash another legendary
recipient of that award who came to
Norway in 2015 to receive another award
for for His Brilliant work he had one
request and that was to meet with Magnus
Carlsen and he did and I know they
talked about Chess for a long time and
tragically after doing so and traveling
back to the US he died in a car crash on
his way from the airport and there is a
fantastic movie about John Nash called A
Beautiful Mind so if you haven't seen it
highly recommend it and we're joined now
also by someone else who is a big fan of
mathematics he's done all the stats for
the meltwater Champions Chester in the
2022 season Ty it's good to see you
again
great to see you are you a big fan of
these recipients of this Noble Prize
award for for economic science be doing
what you do with stats
uh yeah a huge admirer of people who are
actually competent in math instead of
just amateurs like me it's I'm a fan of
them the way I'm a fan of Magnus and
chess
really in combo for us we we met up with
you after we saw you did the chess for
um what is it chess by the Numbers
Twitter account and we figure we need to
bring Thai on the team we need to do
some stats on the tour and you've done a
bunch of them over the last nine months
what has it been like following the tour
and doing all these stats
oh it's been so much fun
um it's stuff that I would have been
interested in looking at anyway but
being able to just really focus on the
tour and dedicate to it let me dig
deeper than I probably would have if I
was just doing it for fun so I found so
much more I got to dig into calculating
uh the FCI calculating performance
ratings and just all sorts of opening
stats and being able to play with all
these different ideas it's been a blast
has anything surprised you at all
looking into these stats
um I've been really surprised by how the
youngsters have done on the tour
um I know we're going to look at our
bonus prizes in a minute and one of them
is essentially the underdog prize it's
how well people have performed above
their Baseline expectation of their feed
day rating
and I knew that the youngsters could
compete but I didn't expect so many to
be up at the top of that prize list and
not just playing to the level we've seen
from them in over the board classical
but playing even stronger than that and
showing us how the degree to which they
may still be underrated in the main
world rankings
yeah absolutely and let's take a look at
those stats that you mentioned so there
are bonus prices this season one of them
is for tour performance over
expectations uh and there's three
categories for players who played at
least one tournament uh for players who
have played at least three ever players
who have played at least five
tournaments and is this set now or can
stuff change here with this game and two
more rapid games to go
this is not at all set
um Arjun and Liam have both been
bouncing back and forth uh with above
and below uh Vincent kymer who is static
at 72.
and if either of them start loses
another game or two today they could
easily drop back below so kymer's still
in contention if Arjun and Liam both
lose another game and also if one of our
Junior Liam starts winning they could
lock it up but there's yeah this game
that we're looking at right now with
Arjun and Prague uh could be a key to
deciding which of those three players
takes down this prize along with Liam's
games with my bedrov wow okay that's
super interesting so we need to keep a
close eye on Arjun and Liam and then we
have the Fighting Chess index which is
something new this season on the tour is
this set
I think this one is pretty set
um Arjun improved from 67.47 to 67.58 in
that last game but it's the way this
formula works it's pretty hard in a
single game to improve it very much you
can if you have a short draw you can
drop it really badly but gains come very
incrementally
so I'm I can't say it's mathematically
impossible for arjune to catch aronian
but I'm I think it's very unlikely that
he will he would have to have probably
three more decisive games today in
openings that are genu generally low
draw rates and they would all have to be
very long games
huh so so those are the factors that
count in on the Fighting Chess index
playing long games and choosing specific
openings and also playing decisive games
yeah those and then with a big penalty
for short draws Which is less than 30
moves
okay super interesting so we will pay
attention to that one as well for Arjun
Eric icy uh who has impressed you the
most this season looking at especially
the tour rating which we introduced this
season
well we've got really late Contender for
that with Wesley so who's after a slow
starts come on really strong and I
definitely hope we get to see more of
him next season because he can clearly
contend for everything on this tour when
if he gets the chance to play enough
events but before that my answer was and
still is Prague Prague has had just such
an incredible season playing his way
into that status of tour regular and
that first time he won a game against
Magnus he didn't even have the greatest
overall tournament that time
and over the year he's matured so much
and at this point it's just standard for
him to be a threat to be at anyone and
to be in contention you expect him in
the regular events to qualify for the
Knockouts you expect him to be winning
matches and majors and that progression
over the course of the Year from
a surprise to just a standby has been
really Pleasant to watch
a huge fan yeah
and the tour rating it's been super
important actually that we got that this
season because we know a player like
Magnus Carlsen is very much motivated by
ratings and I want to ask you can Magnus
finish above 2900 on the tour
he can't he's at 28.92 right now
after the first draw
so
um
you'll lose a point or two
I think he's gonna have to win the next
two games if he wants to finish at 20
over 2900 I think one more draw takes it
off the table but if he can win two and
a half to point five with two two wins
in a row this game and then next game
that would get him there for sure and
let him end the air in style yeah we
should have Tanya run in there and tell
him I can see the bars slightly over to
his side and the tour rating obviously
this is only the first season with it
will that just grow more and more
important as all the players get more
and more games in there
I think so yeah so the way that set up
is
because it was we started this year as
each player played their first event we
seeded it with a their b-day rating as
their Baseline to start from
and then use their games on tour to
watch to let them fluctuate and
stabilize it where they are in this
format but for future Seasons we're
going to carry over their ratings from
this season to next season and only
players that have never been on the tour
before would bring in that provisional
fide rating so yeah we're gonna
definitely just as more players get an
opportunity to compete on the tour and
as the players who were regulars this
year come back and log more games it's
just going to be a more and more stable
measure of how strong are they in this
particular online
hybrid rapid format with
Esports uh philosophy absolutely oh it's
going to be interesting to follow next
season as well so I thank you so much
for the work you've done for the tour
this season and we look forward to
seeing you again next season
absolutely it's been such a pleasure
thank you for joining us
that has given a lot to the tour to
actually have these stats right yeah
he's the Manti we rely on him a lot and
some really fascinating insights as well
I love that phrase esport philosophy I
know that's what we're embracing here
but also the players have been embracing
and uh yeah I mean those those numbers
they all have meanings behind them it
does really back up the fact which is
also kind of seconded by the results uh
these youngsters making their
breakthrough and they're only going to
get better those stats are only going to
be more interesting as the seasons go on
yeah absolutely
and so we did mention the bonus prices
there is one last one and that is for
best game of the season and you now have
eight minutes to cast your vote nine
games have been nominated by all the
experts across the chess 24 streams and
it's your turn now to vote for your
favorite you can see video and you can
go through the games that are nominated
and vote for your favorite and two
players in that game will receive a
bonus price
I think Prague has at least one game in
there oh the most one of the most
beautiful games I've ever seen said by
David Howell that's right one of the
games that I nominated was by Prague of
course when he defeated Jordan van
Forrest and uh really nice nice
sacrificial attack
and meanwhile he's going for something
similar in this game he's really opened
up the center now it has come at the
cost of strategic weaknesses in White's
position white has an isolated e-pawn
that pawn in the center is nicely
blockaded by one of the Black Knights uh
also white Bishops
both have retreated to the first rank
but by opening lines Prague has got
active with his Knight White's Queen
looks nicely placed on the light squares
black might be vulnerable long term
Ivanka yeah definitely if the two
bishops get motoring as you've mentioned
then yes but uh for the time being black
is Rock Solid and doesn't seem to be too
many problems
but uh
I I have to say I wasn't a big fan of
Arjun opening the position like this I
actually thought the position would
remain closed for a lot longer but uh I
guess Arjun was thinking well the
counter player along the dot squares is
going to be sufficient yeah I've got to
say I love his decision to open it up
because when you face the two Bishops
that's rule number one you have to
accelerate the play you can't let white
just stabilize and reorganize and slowly
step forward but yeah it does depend on
the next few moves of course he needs to
justify his decision to open things by
keeping White's light squared Bishop
especially the only unrivaled Bishop
yeah keep that one caged or at least
keep it passive and yeah also I do love
Arjun it's just body language there just
arms crossed as if he's the boss nothing
can disturb him and he only takes he
only kind of breaks from that pose when
he's about to make a move and with eight
minutes he's ready to perhaps I was
going to say activate one of the black
Rooks you could have offered a rook
trade as well he does try to block the
white Queen's diagonal towards the black
king
also direct threat of trying to win
White's epon that Central weakness
I like it uh I like it too it's a very
active move but I have to say you know
there isn't too much of a threat to
actually win the pawn because even if
black if white sorry were to lose this
Pawn then suddenly the bishop that
wasn't doing anything on B1 has kind of
sprung to life so I think in this
particular case the threat is stronger
than the execution yeah and meanwhile
this kind of semi-threat or it's unclear
whether it was a threat it was uh
refuted by White Knight jumping in so no
time to capture that pawn now there's a
double attack hitting the black queen
this Knight had to be removed and white
has indeed opened up his Bishop's
diagonal yvanka you mentioned that this
bishop is now much happier due to the
absence of this Pawn potentially some
life now along this diagonal and also
the creation of a past Pawn this is
either a very strong Pawn in the end
game marching forward
or it could be a weakness that black has
now blockaded he's planted his Bishop on
this square that does have a really
attractive dark Square blockade here the
bishop can never really be removed the
Knight as well on an outpost in the
center can't be kicked by Pawns
and I am fearful that some tactics might
happen against the white King on those
dark squares if the black queen ever
finds her way in uh onto kind of this
diagonal lined up with her Bishop she
ever tries to sneak into H2 that would
spell the end it takes a while to do
that the black queen doesn't have many
safe Parts onto that diagonal but
something to watch out for maybe
definitely and using that same idea you
can even play it in a rather passive way
you can actually Retreat the dark Square
bishop and then line up the queen on D6
and do it that way yeah you could maybe
think of revisioning the queen back and
across just to switch sides The Rook
could swing across uh some hint some
hint of an attack against the white king
but yeah these ideas the kind of fiction
at the moment they're just fantasy but
will they become reality for everybody
if he wants to balance the scores win
this game he'll have to try and go for
that white king
what is Prague doing meanwhile I don't
see any good squares any productive
squares for this bishop likewise this
bishop
maybe it can move to the square but you
have to be careful if your Dart Squad
bishop ever gets exchanged or captured
then white will never fight on that
color complex
I think that's a good move I mean it was
my vibe to actually put that Bishop
challenging the other bishop and then at
the right minute drop it back so it
provides some kind of shelter for the
white king and then you can just start
increasing some pressure against the
Black Knight
I mean white has to bite his time and he
plays it he plays it yeah um it does
look a bit odd I have to say it feels a
bit loose yeah loose is a good word
because yes it's defended this bishop
but for example if black captures it uh
I mean this would be very tempting for
me and then just to move the Knight out
the way there's a bunch of squares you
can put it on a safe Square you can even
Retreat it and dark squares now are a
serious weakness for white along this
diagonal but uh okay he doesn't go for
this I was gonna say maybe you could
even drop the knight in and start
exchanging pieces because once this
Knight is captured and it should be
captured The Rook would fall but this
would have just led to exchanges I
Regice you remember is down in the match
and wants to win so he doesn't want to
swap pieces unless it really helps him
and leaves him in Balance so he drops
his Knight back and he's saying yes okay
you can swap these set of pieces but now
this Black Knight is far more versatile
than the white Bishop White's Bishop a
lousy piece and Black's Knight has a
clear path in towards the white king
along the dark squares so every guy see
offering that trade it was rejected yet
again by Prague he knows that he has to
keep his Bishop here that's White's only
real positive in his position and here
after the Knight stepped back no Bishop
trade he ran to G5
so again it just feels like Prague is
reacting right now it's Eric icy who's
trying to create maybe he'll start
bringing his Knight to attack the White
Queen maybe he'll just Shuffle his Rook
across to the center
it's unclear worse comes to West you
plant your knight back in the middle but
that might lead to a repetition of the
position
I don't think black's in any trouble
here but
you might not be worse are you better do
you have the advantage that's the
question
who would you pick Ivanka black black
now yeah I changed my mind because I'm a
Fickle creature and uh yeah Black's
pieces just look very strong and like
you say white has a big problem on the
dark squares
and uh
it's not easy to fend under and there we
see uh Arjun Retreat his Queen he's
really establishing that dominance over
the dark squares and uh again he's going
to carry on building you know the Rook
now can move maybe the Knight can plant
itself back on the E5 Square it was a
very commanding post after all yep the
night is coming back it's just going to
be hard for white for example even if
white moves now it's just hard to
destabilize black setup how do you kick
this Rook away it takes a long long time
how do you kick this Knight away maybe
you can't and slowly but surely black
will make some progress this Rook can
swing and also notice the king positions
there's three pawns protecting the black
king there's only two protecting the
white king and the two that do protect
the white king aren't well placed so
yeah watch out for whites uh White
facing some tricks later on
yeah
time wise as well having a weaker king
is not great for Prague he's down two
minutes on the clock okay he just pushes
a pawn uh if we go back to the position
he just pushes his a pawn forward but
that doesn't really change much
nope doesn't change anything at all
maybe it was just designed against
Black's Rook coming to attack the White
Queen but it's a passive waiting myth
and now I'm expecting a regassi to
activate his Knight or his Rook the only
two kind of misplaced pieces
optimize those ones and black should be
doing well yeah it's a sleepy move and
the reason I say that is because after
all we do have a caption competition
where we are asking everyone to caption
this picture of Prague asleep I was
resting his head on Ramesh at the
basketball game and Manuel bevand says
that
he's got school tomorrow
and uh Frenchie run captions this
picture by saying the liquid the liquid
death was not an energy drink after all
well that's a very good one and then I
also quite like M's comment who says uh
keep dreaming son keep dreaming
[Music]
and if you two want to enter this
caption this competition remember to
tweet your answer using the hashtag
chesschamps and the winner will get one
this most fabulous t-shirt
it's exclusive to the Champions chess
tour if any few people have this in the
world Simon's t-shirt saying just resign
s and yeah uh great shirt as well I've
got one on under here and I don't think
I decided need to resign this position
but Prague does look at least slightly
more awake than he did in that photo
right now and he has to really wake up
and play a bit quicker on the clock four
minutes his dark Square Bishop's just
been attacked I've got to say I'm not a
fan of what era guys he's just done he's
put a Pawn on a dart square but he's
loosened up whites uh he's loosened up
his light squares white light Square
Bishop at least has some dream of
getting in the game now but I realize he
corrects his last move he gained a bit
of time he corrects that by putting his
pawns to block the potential of White's
light squared Bishop
interesting decision the black king no
longer as safe as it was but maybe he's
got a bit more control everybody in the
center at least
pros and cons behind that last decision
pushing pawns is always
very risky uh maneuver especially in
such a tense middle game
I don't like it David I don't like it
I've sat next to you for too long and
I'm thinking no you can't make those
Pawn weaknesses because for starters
okay I was going to suggest that the
Rook can move across to the open line
but uh Prague just improves his dark
squared Bishop yeah I mean that I guess
on the benefit on the plus side
the white light squared Bishop unless
there's a sacrifice it's never ever
getting in the game now but as you say
especially the E6 Square next to that
black Bishop
eternally and outpost yeah it's a big if
though it's if Prague is quick enough if
White's pieces get into the position he
brought his Dart squared Bishop back but
this piece looks like it's hitting
thinner and Regice he's found another
way around for the Black Knight gaining
time hitting the White Queen the queen
will just swing across as she does and
uh Eric icy jumps in immediately with
his Knight I would just take that off in
a heartbeat and as you can see Prague
agrees and okay now again I'm suddenly
coming around to the idea that black is
much better
and his strategy has paid off although I
do think Prague now has to start taking
some active choices here he can't just
sit back and wait for black to keep on
improving the Rooks I think he has to
either challenge this rook in the middle
of the board or try and take his try and
take control of his own file and put his
Rook on C1 yeah both of those ideas look
very necessary actually you have to
Simply do something with these two
pieces they're asleep just like Prague
was in that photo and you could do that
as you say Ivanka this move yeah I
wasn't looking in this direction
originally but it makes a lot of sense
if you can get into this Square your
Rook will sit nice and pretty and
likewise if you move your other Rook
across if there's a rook trade then you
might sneak into this Square where your
Rook will sit nice and pretty another
Outpost anchored by White's passport
however if you do go for this one black
will say okay let's trade on my terms
and black controls the only open file
suddenly it feels like there might be
some kind of action on the first rank
black might be able to sneak in later
for example the queen could slide across
supporting a future background checkmate
and now White's Rook would not be free
to join the action so the more I look at
it the more I'm inclined towards your
second choice there if I could keep one
defensive rook and Go Active with the
other one and going active with this
Rook
Feels Like the Way Forward Prague
instead Retreats his Bishop
okay what is the idea there maybe to
reroute it to this Square peering down
at the black king maybe just to support
a trade of Rooks on E1 but that feels
like the step in the wrong direction it
cost him a lot of time two and a half
minutes against five
Eric I see he's looked very very good in
this game so far
turning the screw is black now a huge
threat of jumping into the center and
creeping in remember that would end in
Checkmate if Black's Queen ever lines up
on the same diagonal as its Bishop
oh wow David I have news for you
um Prague has to trade off the dark
Square bishop and of course he finds it
anything else would have been losing wow
already the path has narrowed that much
that white is in only moved territory
and this is a pawn sacrifice he had to
go for this we have become accustomed to
Prague finding the best move when
there's only one in the position he's so
accurate he's so precise this is a pawn
sacrifice because the Bishops might
disappear and Eric icy here can simply
grab a pawn however now the Bishops have
disappeared white king is super safe on
the dark squares no more issues there
and remember this Pawn
in an endgame we said it might be a
strength now the blockader has been
removed and only two squares away from
promotion so tables might turn
what a move by Prague I must admit this
is really classy stuff this wasn't on my
radar just giving up a pawn showing no
materialism
just removing Black's best piece and he
saw it so quickly I think perhaps we
would have seen it but perhaps 5-10
minutes down the line after we'd
rejected The Rook moves but uh Prague
you know he took two out two minutes out
time out and then he finds the best move
he knows exactly what needs to be done
he's got four board vision and uh yeah I
like this decision After All Black's
extra Pawn is a double Pawn there on the
right yeah yeah
um no extra porn I mean this double Pawn
just balances out White's extra
essential Pawn so actually I mean if
there is a Trader Bishops yes it's an
extra Pawn but it's just about this past
one right exactly uh White's runner in
the center and also the question now for
Eric icy if he doesn't want to allow the
blockade to go I mean there's a pin on
this line you have to allow the exchange
of Bishops you could set up this
Checkmate threat Queen to H2 sneaking in
but the supporter of that would be
removed and suddenly the replacement of
the bishop is the queen and queens are
known as the worst locators they want to
be active they want to be zooming around
capturing pawns creating threats they
don't want to be sitting and just
guarding a mere Pawn
so suddenly I'd like White's chances at
least of holding the game I don't think
White's ever really playing for the
advantage but
looks like he's uh at least reasserted
some control after being outplayed for
the last 10 15 moves
wow and we will see that Trader Bishops
and suddenly Black's Queen yeah not a
happy piece at all
Prague there we go the evaluation bar
does slide down as well
it's not just that he's such a great
attacker as we've seen throughout the
tour beating Magnus beating some of the
top players in the world but when he's
in trouble he's extremely tenacious
he never lets his head drop and I think
that's a lesson to all the young players
out there just to all players out there
I think the older I get the more my head
drops when I'm being outplayed I'm like
oh I'm not going to save this I don't
believe in my chances but Prague always
looks for those hidden resources
retreating that white Bishop moving it
across sacrificing a pawn it cost him
three moves but he got rid of Black's
best piece
and uh just really really classy stuff
it is definitely classy stuff and
actually ties in very nicely with this
question that we've received from Pepe
Le Pew she's actually watching the show
from New Zealand hello New Zealand and
he says could you explain the difference
between strategy and tactics yeah very
good question so normally when we
commentate on chess we do divide up
different types of position or different
types of move into strategy and tactics
strategy is essentially long-term stuff
so it could be the bishop pair a better
Pawn structure it's very static things
that you see in a position tactics are
direct variations it's like forcing
moves checks captures threats I have to
play something the opponent has to react
I play another move the opponent has to
react tactics often do involve double
attacks and uh yeah they often involve
just kind of pushing your opponent down
a forced path yeah that's a very good
question I've actually wondered that by
itself yeah and so I actually have a
very good quote from
who says strategy with without tactics
is the slowest route to Victory tactics
without strategy is the noise before the
defeat ah very true oh that's a good way
to put it yeah
yeah I think there's another quote as
well I can't quite remember who said it
but they said uh tacticians know what to
do when there's something to do but
strategists they know what to do when
there's nothing to do so if there's
nothing to do in a position uh
strategists they just improve their
pieces they look for the long-term
advantages I would class myself in that
type of uh kind of mold but yeah
tacticians like Prague or like I mean
the great world champions Tile For
example and modern players like
managerov when there's something to do
they spot these really aggressive ways
to give their position energy to go for
checkmate just go for the opponent's
king and are you either or can you be
both if your Magnus Carlson or both
otherwise you're usually in one or the
other Camp it often reflects your
personality as well tacticians tend to
be you know players who want to live in
the moment and go for fun go for
spectacular uh I I'm more of a kind of
results based all about the numbers all
about the stats I'd rather avoid defeat
than uh risk
so yeah I mean you can be both of course
nowadays in modern chess the top players
they're very Universal so proud Prague I
would say as well he's good at both yeah
and I can see that origin is actually
improving his position using strategy to
his benefit but uh having a look at
other results and other games and I can
see that Magnus Carlsen he is winning
against Yankton wow due to that but I
have to say I mean it's not necessarily
that clear Magnus is facing an attack oh
okay so anything can happen and we know
Duda is resourceful right yes yeah dude
okay he doesn't have a positive uh
expression on his face however but he's
very good usually at turning things
around so he's got to believe will the
Tilt continue that's the problem with
tilt sometimes you can just play good
moves you play the position that's put
in front of you but as soon as things
start to turn your your head goes and
I'm wondering whether we switch over
because this game looks like it might be
headed towards a draw
um we do see the pawns disappearing the
Queens have left the board you get my
vote of approval yeah let's see if we
can make that happen perhaps because
that Magnus game extremely exciting this
game will fizzle towards a draw because
white sea Pawn will disappear Black's
b-pawn will disappear it's just gonna be
three pawns each and no weight to just
balance this one so prag did find a way
towards safety
and I wonder can we make that happen
and we switch over yeah absolutely we'll
see whether the magic can happen yeah
and I mean let's do it try it okay can
we click our fingers this game is headed
towards a draw all Rick and games are
drawn as they say uh we'll see now that
white porn white seaporn be captured and
white will regain the material yeah and
that means Prague will stay in the lead
he won the first game if he wins game
three he's gonna win the match or
generic guys he needs to win either game
three and or four do you either win the
match or take it to tie breaks but we're
going to jump to Duda Carlson where
Magnus Carlson can take the lead against
this big rival this season the first
game was a draw
and remember what Ty said as well if
Magnus wins this game and the next one
he's going to finish the season above
2900 on the tour ratings that must be a
motivation as well what's happening on
this board wow and we've jumped in and
there's just been a tactical melee we
just missed a really nice tattoo by
Magnus which we will show in a second
but he got the Queens off the board he
was facing a serious attack Black's King
was in trouble but when you're facing an
attack swap queens and he achieved this
and now let's do a quick count it's Rook
for Bishop but more importantly black
has four extra pawns so black is
seriously ahead and all black needs to
do is keep those pawns intact Rooks are
very good at chasing down pawns uh the
black Bishop isn't as agile but it must
be winning Ivanka those pawns must be
too strong it has to be I mean 100
that's very confident talking by me but
I mean those pawns must be superior I
probably would say that it's not
necessarily the e-pawn or the G Pawn
that is going to win the game but
instead it will being Seaborn and those
pawns there on the left so what would be
the winning idea you don't want to push
all your pawns forward too far because
White's Rook will happily just Hoover
them off the board but I guess you need
the black king Black's King might start
racing towards the center it's far away
right now both kings are but it looks
like Black's King has a clearer path
into the center than when the white one
does and do the still shaking his head
maybe just while Duda is uh kind of at
least trying to save this position we
can show what just happened before we
jumped in it was just one or two moves
before we joined the action where Magnus
clinched the decisive Advantage it was
here Black's King is under heavy fire
from White's two Rooks and from the
White Queen it looks really scary but
Magnus offered this queen exchange just
stepped across and when Duda put his
Queen on the edge of the board Magnus
sacrifices Queen temporarily for the
white rook and created this pin winning
the material back winning the White
Queen for blacks rook and suddenly we do
catch up with the game let's see what
the players have chosen Magnus has just
eliminated this remaining white Portland
A2 at the cost of his own pawn and A7
are now retreating
the question is can he keep his four
pawns alive if the bishop alone is not a
great defender he might need his King
Magnus
he does look like a big ask for White's
Rook to go and grab all of these four
pawns so dude shuffles his King across
but now it may be the March will begin
Black's Bishop will defend one pawn and
it's these two that you mentioned Ivanka
these two are gonna run yeah and they're
going to be protected as well and then
it's just a matter of time you know
slowly but surely wins the race like the
tortoise then it's just about
introducing the king into the game and
the Rook can't keep an eye on all the
pawns and someone has to start doing the
defensive work and there you see Duda
move his work he's threatening to push
to move his Rook once up the board and
that's why Magnus just advances his
Seaport yeah he's advancing in Seaport
so now if this move does happen Ivanka
he's happily gonna start running yeah
and uh he's going to abandon this Pawn
of course because it's these two that
are going to win the day so Duda goes
off to the black B Pawn but he's gonna
find his pieces stuck surely after black
pushes I'm not sure which Pawn you
should push but for example if you push
the C Pawn surely there's no time to
come and stop these black pawns suddenly
black can just put his pawns on these
squares this Pawn completely paralyzes
the white Rook this Pawn will keep the
white king honest and it might
eventually be the G Pawn that wins the
day
the black king now has all the Time in
the World to start moving across to
start kicking the white Rook away and uh
wow you've predicted the future
correctly is exactly what's happening
and The Rook has gotten behind the
passport and we're expecting the e-pawn
to push Magnus doesn't even flinch
he just knows exactly what he has to do
yeah this is the most beautiful Bishop
you'll ever see acting as a guardian of
those two past pawns and white is
absolutely paralyzed this is one case
where a rook is far worse than a minor
piece than a bishop and too many pawns
looks like another end game master class
from Magnus King is going to start
approaching now yeah Black's King is
coming and that will spell the end
that's the missing ingredient and uh of
course three Pawns
it's going to be hard it's going to be
an uphill struggle for Duda to deal with
all of these Runners you can deal with
two of them with your two pieces but you
can't deal with all three
yeah I mean Magnus we thought he might
take his foot off the pedal but already
with his opening choices today he's
asked early questions of Duda and look
at this he's not even using the black
king he doesn't need to this black G
Pawn is going to come and kick away the
white king one of these three pawns is
going to promote I think it's inevitable
now could all of them promote or maybe
two of them if if uh dude allowed him to
go on for long enough
yeah one is enough one Queen's enough
for checkmate but why stop at one and
here we go the promise White's King
cannot stop two pawns on its own White's
Rook is stuck behind the sea Pawn I
think we'll see Duda resign less than 10
seconds as well okay he gives up his
Rook for one Pawn but uh now the black
Bishop can just Retreat as long as you
keep your remaining Pawn as a future
Queen you win the game and Magnus with a
nice killer touch giving up his Bishop
King takes Bishop the black porn has a
free run through and there's no way to
win that black pawn so Duda does resign
we have a win four minus Crossing on
this final day he takes the lead and the
match against his big rival this season
young crest of Duda if he wins game
three he's gonna also win the match on
the final day on fire Magnus Carlson
foreign
total control from the start in this
game would you agree
um yeah I think E5 was
um probably overzealous I think he had
decent compensation but it wasn't so
easy to prove uh and then yeah later
it's very important that I have this
plan to bring the bishop to A6 I feel
like most of the time I'm in time there
and after I sacked The Exchange I felt
like I should be much better obviously
there is always counter play
but it didn't seem like it didn't seem
like it was enough
again this really interesting 986 in the
opening he went into a long thing do you
think it had an unsettling effect on
Duda
yeah I mean
um
I think
um he was making a choice there either
um either has to play something uh quiet
after which you know I set up
I have a blockade on E5 and then we just
maneuver for for a long time or he
probably felt that he can try and do
something
more more decisive but maybe it wasn't
too easy but very much according to his
style to go for E5 and Dynamics I
surprised with the kind of clock
difference that's going on in the last
two games
yeah I'm just
just taking it a little bit easy
um when it comes to that just
trying to play more by intuition than
than before and certainly when the
complications happened
um
right at the end
um with Queen E6 and thus
simplification like having it's
having a testament it's helped a lot
it's working so far good luck for the
next one
[Music]
mentioned in his interview here Magnus
as black is under some serious pressure
it looks like White's heavy pieces are
going all out for the black king however
staying aired on the clock in Rapid
chess is vital Magnus mentioned he had
eight minutes dude only had a few
seconds left and using all his time on
the clock Magnus found a nice way to
defend he simply shuffled his Queen
across and this actually forces the
Queens off the board when your king is
weak get those Queens off and here white
can't go for the queen trade immediately
he tried to do that to keep his Queen on
the board using this pin it looks like
the White Queen cannot be captured but a
nice temporary Sacrifice from Magnus he
captured the white Rook with a check
forcing White's Queen back and now this
nasty pin won the game the White Queen
cannot save itself it has to give itself
up for the black rook and as we saw
later on Magnus because he had such a
big time advantage on the clock was able
to push these three Pawns to Victory
really nice tactics in order to ensure a
winning end game
[Music]
Magnus Carlton can decide the match in
game three
if he wins it's with the white pieces he
will win the match against John
Christoph Duda who is down by one point
but young Crystal Duda has played some
amazing chess this season and in the
Oslo Esports cup he eventually became
the surprise winner
and there it is due to win this match
wow and will he also now win the
tournament I
end this match that means right now he
is in the lead in the Oslo Esports cup
the blindness of the white Rook could
just step forward one square and capture
a Blackboard
[Music]
he's just hallucination he forgot this
pool was up for grabs he resigns he
offers a handshake to the great Muhammad
Yaro who played just some fantastic
chess today to win the match against
Magnus Carlsen and Shake everything up
obviously Liam must be nervous he knows
that if he wins this he wins the
tournament we're heading towards a draw
in this game that means tie breaks it
also means Duda wins the tournament a
draw is inevitable now
Bishop disappears
they do double fist pumps
young Crystal dude that wins the Oslo
Esports cup
it's very nice to win the tournament
actually I didn't believe I have a real
chance
before before today before now so
um yeah I'm just typing you know to play
good class here
I was a nice moment for a young Crystal
dude and we mostly had really nice
moments during the season of the world
torture Champions chess tour but during
the first tournament this season Russia
invaded Ukraine and for the second
tournament this season we decided to
team up with the UNICEF so together with
UNICEF the players and our partners the
second tournament this season was called
the the charity cup and was a fundraiser
for the children affected by the war in
Ukraine
so we are now calling on the chess
Community our partners and all of you
our viewers to come together and help
those in desperate need by donating to
UNICEF who is providing life-saving
support to the people in and around
Ukraine this is so far status in our
fundraiser after only a few hours I'm so
impressed more than thirteen thousand
dollars the auction also for David's
chest tie is about to end one minute and
14 seconds left the current bid I think
is it 700 it's 700 wow it's a golden
the golden tie I don't know what to say
everyone uh whoever wins it I hope it
brings you a lot of luck on the
chessboard and thank you as well for
your generosity uh for Ukraine yesterday
together with all of you we were able to
raise more than 20
000 we have now raised our goal to 75 I
am being told that you're actually
donating all of your price money in this
tournament to to units of is that
correct
yeah I figured it'd be a good time to
contribute in my own way I would have
hoped to score more points I'll never
make it to the knockout because it was
100 of whatever whatever I scored so I
think in the end four thousand dollars I
think I was I won so not bad I would
have liked to have done better towards
it for the charity but I think it's a
good initiative so far we've been able
to
well donate more than twenty thousand
dollars thanks to our play Magnus
charity challenge so we invite guests in
the studio to play Magnus at 10 years
old and we donate money to UNICEF per
move that they're able to make and today
David you're gonna get your chance for
revenge against Magnus 10 years old I
got this
oh
oh yes
yes 69. 69 moves that means FDX will so
kindly donate six thousand nine hundred
dollars to UNICEF and our fundraiser for
Ukraine Okay who wants to do that
trading things off okay he's got a great
position still but only five seconds for
Christian capture that Pullman Center go
on move two seconds one second and the
clock's running out
five moves you're also going to let us
auction out a pair of your Puma football
shoes so thank you so much for that as
well and you're gonna sign them as well
right
yes I'll make sure to sign them and uh
I'll be you know giving those so I'm
really excited about that now it says
closed auction meaning the signed
chessboard by Magnus Carlsen finally
went for eight thousand six hundred
dollars all money going to UNICEF I mean
that must be the most expensive
chessboard ever it's been heartwarming
to see how the chess Community has come
together for the people of Ukraine we
ended up on
158 thousand dollars that is incredible
we started out with a goal of twenty
thousand dollars and here we are thanks
to all of you at home a big big thank
you
fantastic that is uh you said it David
one of your favorite tournaments this
season yeah it was just so touching that
the whole chess Community came together
our viewers thank you so much for being
so generous uh all of you and we had
some cool events going on every day
um yeah the whole Chess World uniting
that was uh yeah for me that was one of
the highlights of the year I agree
really came together again thank you to
everyone who did join in that fundraiser
it's getting close now to game threes
here in the tour finals final day we've
had a vote going the whole tournament
for best game of the 2022 season the
Voting is now closed and we have the
results the winner the best game of the
mouthwater championship tour 2022 is
Magnus Carlsen against alireza ferrugia
from the crypto cup it received almost
20 percent of your votes this game was a
win for Magnus Carlsen let's take a look
at it
game one Carlson wins a wild and
wonderful tactical battle seconds left
on the clock getting complicated it's
getting really complicated it's coming
in this this is messy Checkmate will end
the game that night drops it's two Rooks
and a bishop against the queen is too
many material too many pieces Mike's
King will move next to White Queen will
jump back and defend and
there we go Magnus takes the first Blitz
game
this was an important win for Magnus in
Loveless game you seemed a little
surprised that this was the winner yeah
I was expecting it to be managera's
amazing sacrifices against Anish giri
where he gave up all of his pieces
pretty much to win the game but uh all
of those games were worthy candidates
and the people have spoken Carlson wins
yet another break he's winning them all
Magnus Carlsen what a season it's been
for him and he's now in the lead Against
The Duda on this final day two draws
between Wesley son and nishikiri that
will definitely go to game four Arjun
aragaisi he needs to win at least one of
the two next games to take it to tie
breaks against Prague Prague if he wins
game three he will win the match
two wins against mobdiaro today with a
drawing game three he's gonna win the
match Magnus Carlsen with a great win in
game two against Duda means dudo needs
to make a comeback minus with a win in
game three we'll finish off the season
with a match win inside Shaq 15. we will
follow this game Magnus Carlsen will
have the white pieces and what do you
expect this could be his final game of
the season yeah he's gonna push hard
yeah you know he smells blood he senses
that Duda is perhaps tilting is upset
with himself so what what other than
just to put the pressure on early on and
surprise Duda and then just enjoy the
game and the great thing about Magnus
you know he can just relax and enjoy the
situation he has like he's won
everything literally everything so he
might as well just play with abandon it
doesn't really matter what happens yeah
and that interview that we had with
Magnus earlier is very telling he's
adopting the aronian strategy just
trusting your instincts playing quickly
confidently and when the critical
moments happen later having those extra
minutes on the clock is so important
meanwhile this game has started as in as
a Sicilian Defense an open Sicilian
where we see an exchange of Pawns on D4
very early that means some open lines
potentially some big attacks early in
the game at least the climax of this one
will be much earlier no more in-game
grinds the open Sicilian
that is yeah very ambitious Magnus not
just knuckling down playing for the draw
he's playing his principled
uh favorite openings here if Magnus into
this game it's not only going to win the
match and finish off in style he will
finish the season as Ty mentioned above
2900 and not only that he's going to
finish off on a peak tour rating
it's like a clean sweep yeah he wins the
tour one tournament early he wins it to
a final tournament early you know he's
won five of the tour events yeah he's
like over one the best to be 2900 yeah I
mean
someone has to stop him
there was any doubt he is still the best
player in the world I think he is
proving it in the mouth of the Champions
chest or in a great mood with his music
on
again you know again you know when
you're kind of training chess and you're
going through all the Motions I mean
you're kind of told you know you should
just focus 100 on chess you should just
be in deep concentration and Magnus is
like nope don't need to be in the zone I
can just enjoy the music and play chess
I'm also fantastic at multitasking I
mean is there anything that Magnus can't
do yeah it's uh
this this I mean it's depressing for all
of his Rivals out there uh I mean Magnus
he's just yeah he's just at his Peak how
can you even fight against this level
that he's displayed the whole week it's
it's just amazing uh to watch him we're
so lucky here to have front row seats uh
to yeah one of the greatest plays of all
time showing his best chess and it did
start as an open Sicilian and now the
position has actually transposed to uh
an English opening uh we did see a bunch
of exchanges Knights disappearing
yeah this is a definite advert for just
being happy being relaxed when you play
because that's often when the best ideas
come to your mind if you're too focused
too stressed then often you have tunnel
vision you get two kind of um kind of
attached to certain moves when you have
to have a broad picture of the whole
board it's also the modern generation we
see streamers nowadays listening to
music chatting to their fans and playing
yeah all the top players there
multitaskers yeah I don't know how they
do that because whenever I've streamed
it's like blunder Central and it becomes
a bit embarrassing and anyhow the
players are actually still following a
game that was played between Magnus
Carlson and Vichy Anand in 2018 and that
game ended in a draw yeah I think I
remember that game
that one Magnus didn't achieve much from
the opening but he was never in that
much danger either if I remember so
that's maybe perfect for the match
situation Magnus doesn't necessarily
want to take too much risk he wants to
get a playable position with some
stability there's been an exchange of
pieces so white Pawn structure long term
is very damaged those two doubled C
pawns however you have the bishop pair
so often at the right moment one of the
C pawns might step forward as the
opponent C4 you might even give a pawn
back just in order to activate those
Mighty Bishops seems to be a theme of
the
kind of tournament so far ivanko just
one side obtaining the bishop pair
trying to keep it for later and it's
always a battle will that be a factor
will that be effective sometimes it is
sometimes not yeah there need to be a
there needs to be a course called The
Mighty Bishops like the I don't know why
I was thinking that the Mighty Ducks is
actually what I was running through my
mind that was a great film by the way
no one tell me otherwise yeah nostalgia
and uh meanwhile you mentioned that game
Magnus has got pedigree in this position
he played it against Vichy Anand one of
the greats of World Chess how did that
game continue so it kind of continued
exactly the same way that you said
actually white sacrificing the sea porn
it uh black captured and after white
played F3 supporting the Santa
he just simply developed his pieces and
did what Magnus likes to do you know he
actually developed his that's where
Bishop pushed the a pawn moved his Rook
over to an open line and got very
pleasant position yeah and I think this
is essential that Magnus pushed this
Pawn now if you had delayed for example
a more sleepy player a slower type of
strategy player might have just pushed a
pawn first but suddenly Black's Queen
would jump out hitting these weaknesses
notice how it's not possible to
sacrifice your front Pawn anymore also
the Black Knight could come round to
blockade these two Eternal weaknesses by
giving this Pawn up immediately Magnus
is saying yes I'm going to be a pawn
down but in this position look at your
pawns are these two pawns really better
than just one
the front Pawn especially on C5 is going
to be extremely weak once the white
Bishop lines up against it the queen can
also line up against it on the diagonal
it's going to be hard to hold this Pawn
long term so it's a very much long-term
sacrifice but also it's to free up the
Bishops which White's Bishop actually
has a very nice Square now to blockade
in front of those pawns yeah so it's a
Liberation sacrifice it's freeing your
pieces but you're also saddling your
opponent with those long-term weaknesses
and your you've actually highlighted the
best move for white on the board oh wow
a pure accident I tell you Ivanka he
doesn't play it he pushes his Pawn to F3
yeah I mean I I vaguely remember
studying this as white one time when I
was attempted to play this opening via
the English uh move order uh rather than
the Sicilian but I do remember the
bishop often came to this square and
white porn steps forward black tries to
at least occupy or take some control
over the square in front of his pawns
now Black's Bishop is lined up also
against a long-term weakness and Magnus
just continues to develop it feels like
it should be balanced black is a
temporarily a pawn up and he should be
able to give back that this Pawn at the
right moment to trade off some pieces or
uh to just
at least cost quite a bit of time yeah
but yeah for now the pressure is
definitely on duty and the game is
literally following Magnus Carlson's
earlier games so Magnus will be in his
element you know he's played this
position before he's quite experienced
I'm sure he has a small Improvement up
his sleeve somewhere
and uh is do you think Duda knows what
he's doing
quite possibly Duda has studied this or
something similar before but it's
unlikely he's looked at it recently and
he will not have predicted this that's
the another kind of reason why Magnus is
so successful with experimenting with
openings because he's always got an idea
he always has some kind of experience in
these openings Magnus but he's
unpredictable because he plays
Everything his opponents can never
predict what he's going to do on the
morning of the game they have to look at
four or five different openings and
therefore they kind of split their time
they divide their time and no matter
what opening he chooses the opponent's
knowledge is always superficial they
have to study four things yes they might
predict one but they wouldn't have gone
as deep as he has so Magnus is he
singing
he's been doing that today listening to
his music sing when you're winning yeah
yeah and uh okay there has been a
development actually because the Dude is
night retreat was different to what was
played in the game and Vichy actually
didn't touch that night at all instead
preferred to move the queen so now
Magnus will be feeling very comfortable
okay
yep Magnus can choose he can occupy this
line This open line with this Rook he
can start gaining space this is a very
Magnus move pushing this Pawn forward
trying to push it all the way up just
for the end game when it's ready to
start being a nuisance ready to start
trying to promote another idea for
example could be to just sidestep with
the White Queen okay there we go it's
just classic Magnus uh he pushes a ball
and gains some space and yeah pressure
all on black Black's night misplaced
Black's Queen passive and these are ugly
pawns and he cannot lose this game me
and Kristoff do that Magnus will win the
match he was in a great mood when he
arrived the arena today Tanya you asked
the Magnus about Wesley Seoul playing
Sinister Magnus before each games I
wanted to ask you what is the story with
Wesley so and Sinister Magnus
it's also mysterious Gaia so every day a
Wesley comes on and he's been mentioning
that he plays these warm-up games online
before the matches start and over the
last couple of days he's been playing a
certain player uh going by the handle
Sinister Magnus uh Wesley says he's
around 3000 rated and he's been out
playing Wesley and now that's not
something that you usually do you don't
outplay Wesley in Blitz Games and in
bullet games but that's what's been
happening uh Wesley was wondering if
that is magnus's secret account or
what's going on there because he has no
idea who Sinister Magnus is but he did
say that well getting those losses has
been helping him play his games here and
matches here and winning them because he
kind of gets done with all the games
that he has to lose we asked Magnus
today is he Sinister Magnus Magnus
declined it but we also learned well
Magnus might not have been playing
Wesley but he's been up till 3am playing
against Daniel naroditsky some more
chess clearly the world champion can't
have enough of the game he's playing
here he's up all night till 3am playing
against some of the best players in the
world it's still a mystery who is
Sinister Magnus
super interesting inside Tonya Sinister
Magnus I think we need to start an
investigation on Twitter who is Sinister
Magnus yeah you can tweet us using the
hashtag test terms I mean I don't think
it would be like it couldn't be Magnus I
mean it's kind of obvious I remember his
reaction though so first he said huh
what and then he said oh now I
understand sort of yeah is he bluffing
Magnus is he double bluffing is he
trying to keep his identity a secret he
normally goes Anonymous if he can and if
you have a rating online on leeches of
3000 it means you're one of the elite
one of the best Blitz players out there
I think uh this is on chess.com and
Magnus has a rating of 3200 on his named
account so he's even better than
Sinister Magnus but 3000 is very strong
I struggle to break that uh boundary
that threshold it's it must be a very
very strong player that Wesley's uh
sparring against who is Sinister Magnus
oh I'm so curious right now so what is
it you David uh I wish I wish I could
meet Wesley so but uh it's not me
unfortunately whoever it is does have a
picture of Magnus in the profile he does
have magnus's name and a Norwegian flag
next to the uh next to it so I'm just
looking at it right now yeah the mystery
continues yeah it's not Magnus I don't
think so no it's it's a it's a spoof
account yeah often what Magnus does play
online it's either his kind of official
account or it's yeah very random
Anonymous names that nobody can figure
out until
he reveals it himself on a stream for
example could it be the Norwegian
juniors
maybe are they strong enough to take
down Wesley so consistently I'm not so
sure there can only be a handful of
players in the world surely maybe it's
Nakamura just uh controlling and
Sinister what sort of does that mean is
it like a name or is it yeah cinnamon
Sinister means like creepy scary
creepy magnets creepy Magnus
oh yeah it's it's always fascinating
there's so many accounts that I play
when I play online on any website you
know I just want to know who it is
sometimes you can get a gist from their
moves you can kind of guess just from
their style of play but if they're
really strong and they're just out
playing every game you just want to know
you don't want to lose to just some
faceless nameless person
for Wesley it's also interesting it's
instructive that Magnus has been playing
a lot online during this tournament just
to stay sharp stay fresh Wesley's doing
the same and that's brought them success
it's a bit like for example in tennis
you see even before the match they're
warming up with a team they're warming
up against their opponent that's what
the top chess players in the world are
doing now these days no more just
sitting in your room just kind of
staying calm doing nothing you have to
play chess in order to be fresh
very very strange who is Sinister Magnus
a 3 000 rated player online leeches
named himself after Magnus Carlson
beating Wesley so
I'm looking at the results very
impressive results as well just reading
some very strong Blitz specialists
so it must be
ah I don't know who this view is we need
your help yeah investigate Sherlock
Holmes if you're out there let us know
and Tonya also saying Magnus is up all
night playing Blitz against norditsky
yeah yeah it's uh naroditski he's played
on the tour he's great I mean not just a
world-class commentator but
so fast on the mouse yeah I can't
compete with his speed nowadetsky so
quick Blitz and bullet yeah I can tell
you how I was how I lost two hours of my
life today I was on that new Magnus
chess Academy out playing Ace in the
sleeve Kaya what have you introduced
Mia's house too I was so addicted I know
and the music comes on and you feel like
James Bond selling all these sound
effects yeah and I was like before I
knew it two hours had gone I had matched
a niches of results but I hadn't beaten
Christopher which I was kind of annoyed
about 72 right yeah that's seven it's
69. 69 is Anisha well that's still super
good remember everyone the new Magnus
chess Academy app is released it is
world number one Magnus carlsen's very
own official app
and it's available for download now both
for Apple devices and the Android and in
the app there's just a bunch of really
really cool games they're fun
but they're also going to help you
improve your chests and Magnus even said
he's getting hooked on it as well
and we all are yeah you practice chess
as the top players do you learn pattern
recognition all that but also yeah
gaming it's fun and much more sensible
to spend your time on than for example
Candy Crush
which is just pointless you don't learn
anything you don't improve your brain
capacity but using this app you will get
smarter definitely and you will also
enjoy yourself and it does look like
Magnus is thinking hard and whilst he's
contemplating perhaps snoozing
um well we do have a caption this
competition where we're asking the
viewers at home to caption this picture
of young Prague falling asleep at the
basketball game and uh Sterling says
Prague came to the Warriors game to get
a taste of the American dream
I love these puns you're always win me
over with those kind of jokes and uh one
two three four Triple E one two three
four that was a nice handle it says the
road to the world champion is long and
tired that's a good one that is a very
good one and if you two have a caption
for this picture remember to tweet us
using the hashtag chess jams and one
winner will win the is highly exclusive
Simon Williams just resign I mean you're
surely going to intimidate all your
opponents wearing this t-shirt I want
one as well I know right now there's
only three in the world it's David
wearing one it's this one and of course
we're gonna send one to Simon as well
we can pray for it can we snag one as
well yeah yeah okay because I can't wait
to wear at my next test one of myself
busted over powerful exactly and
meanwhile we do see a move from Magnus
he marches forward with the queen to
take control of the d-line yeah however
the evaluation bar shows a big reaction
to this move
really doesn't like White's position to
me it looks like white should be fine
yes you're a pawn down but everything
else is harmonious everything else is
protected Black's pawns remember aren't
ideally placed but it might be due to
the combination of the pieces Queen and
Knight often work better as a team than
Queen and Bishop and black has full
control Duda is even feeling confident
enough to push his H Pawn down the board
he's going to try to go for the white
king later it's still going to take a
while but Black's Queen and Knight will
be able to help out first he wants to
create some holes he wants to just ruin
the white Pawn structure on that flank
so that H Pawn is going as far down the
board as possible also the black king is
given some breathing space and Ivanka
are you surprised to see the evaluation
bar so far in Black's favor
it is surprising but uh
when I look at it deeply I'm not that
surprised actually even that sounds like
a big contradiction but I mean if you
take a look at Black's pieces they're
all fantastically placed you know the
Rook is primed to jump to the second row
the black queen can also step in the
night can spring forward yeah you know
you have weak pawns on the left side of
the board but then a biggie it's more to
do with peace activity and Magnus
offering a trade of queens and whoa the
valuation bar has really shot up yeah it
looks like Duda might even have a
winning Advantage maybe he just has to
take the Queens off and play the end
game that's not easy psychologically to
do against Magnus but if you do take the
Queens off then suddenly look at White's
pieces they're not well placed yes
you're going after one porn but after
for example a check and another check
which king is driven back it's still in
the first Rank and now black has a
choice do you go for this Pawn looks
very juicy very tempting impossible for
white to defend you could even go for
this pawn and either way you will emerge
one Pawn up he does take the Queens off
the board Duda and I think he's going to
go for this variation I'm not sure which
porn I would go for to be honest but
maybe this one and uh here I think Duda
just has a clear Pawn Advantage he goes
for the other Pawn instead but
essentially uh Black's Rook is going to
move across and black is going to start
pushing this a pawn down the board
okay Magnus he's gonna try and hold the
same game he is the end game Maestro
remember so we do see black has grabbed
a pawn but maybe it wasn't the correct
one because white is going to regain
this guy on A5 this Pawn is now dropping
no matter what
maybe Duda with over 10 minutes on the
clock Rush that decision
I think he should have gone for the
other Pawn because this is the more
dangerous Runner it's the outside pass
Pawn it's harder to stop if black just
has this Pawn as his
has his uh extra material this one is
easier to stop running down the board
yeah I meant but that's the kind of
decision that you you kind of appreciate
the advantage and the disadvantages of
in hindsight yeah
in hindsight Duda maybe had a bigger
Advantage he still should be doing well
I'm expecting him to move his Rook
across and after a capture of a pawn
he'll take back and the question is
whether he can convert
black does have an extra Pawn remember
but he's got a weakness here a weakness
there points Bishop is quite good yeah
and and how is a potential media
actually can I defend the pawn first of
all actually maybe not in this exact
position
I don't see a way to defend it because
for example if you step your Pawn
forward uh to defend this guy then you
lose your knight if you move your knight
into the center to block this bishop
then white can happily just take a pawn
and restore the balance if white wins
all the queen side pawns and it's just
on the king side then it will be a draw
so Duda may be facing a dilemma how does
he maintain his Advantage could it be
for example stepping back with the rook
and then now doing something Fancy with
the Knight jumping into this square or
this Square uh this Pawn this white
apron is not running away anytime soon
so you can take it at leisure
but dude is looking down he's looking
away that's normally his calculating
face he's trying to work out whether he
can stay upon up in this end game
computer says yes but he needs to prove
it
what do you think Ivanka serious winning
chances or more likely that Magnus can
hold
questions I want to say I
there is winning chances but um the
analysis that we just showed on the
board kind of demonstrated otherwise
so I mean maybe you could be clever for
example in this variation we showed
after Bishop takes porn Rook takes porn
oh sorry maybe I should go the other way
I was going to do something clever but I
have to be accurate The Rook could go
behind and uh here Duda maybe could give
a check first and only then drop back
because now when White's Bishop Retreats
black can give a nasty check along this
line and when the king moves the Knight
could come in and uh start going for
pawns along the second round he's done
something similar Duda he's gone
immediately for the second rank but the
evaluation bar doesn't like what he's
done he hasn't gone after White's a pawn
will he regret that will that pawn
promote uh this Pawn could be dangerous
later if white can advance it first he's
gone for the G Pawn instead
interesting but it feels he's losing
control yeah it feels rushed he's got
eight and a half minutes and this Pawn
can simply step forward for example that
would be one option
Magnus could even ignore that just maybe
move his Bishop backwards out the way
start pushing pawns himself
it's the move that I would be tempted I
mean I'm not a very patient person so I
would be thinking okay fine I can keep
the a pawn alive move the bishop out of
the way to B6 and then get compensation
that way after all the G pawns feel
slightly irrelevant but then again then
again this requires calculation because
we mustn't forget that black will also
have a path H Pawn so
for example this Pawn could start
running and we could see a race who is
quicker and when it comes to any pawn
race you have to pause you have to spend
some time calculating for the first time
in the in the match today actually
Magnus is below on the clock spending a
lot of time I'm expecting either as you
mentioned Ivanka moving up this bishop
clearing a path for the white a pawn or
you step forward to kick the Black
Knight but the question there would be
whether you actually help kick Black's
Knight to a better Square uh maybe the
Knight sitting in the center would
actually help the black porn Advance who
knows it's up to Magnus
he is seriously Under Pressure he's
holding this potentially with best play
but he needs to be accurate and okay he
doesn't go for any of those options he
moves the king across instead so this
one is similar I guess he's giving up
the G pawn and next move he'll swing
back with his Bishop bar jumps up again
for Duda yeah uh I expect the bar to
swing quite a bit because this is one of
those end games it's going to end up in
a pawn race no matter what similar to
what we showed it might not be exactly
what we showed but along those lines and
for humans I think that's where we see
the biggest difference between humans
and computers computers calculate so
well so accurately they'll never ever
blunder in a race but humans can count
incorrectly they can maybe assume that
they're quicker but the opponent might
have a small clever move to win that
race and uh yeah we see Magnus not quite
at his best in this game at least
I see a bunch of you Tweeting about
Sinister Minds we're so curious about
who it is and Tonya actually she got an
interview with Wesley so after game two
against Anita Geary they are now playing
game three they are tied but I don't
know now that Wesley mentioned Sinister
Wagner so let's take a look at what
Wesley said before this game three
Wesley two draws in this match so far uh
seemed like a pretty even fight would
you agree
yeah yeah for sure I mean God expected
it and issues for
being top player since he was a kid very
much known each other for a long time I
also one of the best if not the best
prepared player in the opening he really
knows his stuff he plays a lot of
openings and he finalized it deeply he
knows the structures very well he knows
the plants uh
again I'm not sure why he lost so many
games in this tournament I would never
have expected in million years but it's
going to be a very tough match up to as
expected yes well you got two best
players fighting each other that's what
we want we do have an update for you
Wesley that we asked Magnus if he was
the secret opponent uh as Sinister
Magnus that you were having your warm-up
games against he declined it yeah yeah I
mean who
I wonder what else could be because I
played him
today been a 5-0 played him yesterday he
beat me by three points so I think a
total score is uh
ten and a half
or that whoever that is and I have two
and a half
now and that can be Hikaru so yeah
I can't really think of too many people
in the world who can beat me and live
ten and a half two and a half so unless
that guy if you think a machine or
whatever I mean that that couldn't be
just some random I am right but in any
case I was actually watching the real
Magnus play last night unless someone
borrow this account but that's gotta be
him but I was watching him last night he
was playing some games against Daniel
noraditski if I watch a few games but I
think they played
AF 70s two games and I think they played
until three in the morning
so I I also like was warming up in the
evening at night but I mean Michael's
playing till three in the morning it's
insane absolutely while the warm-up
games have been working out for you
before you solve the mystery of who it
is you've
used
oh that's so interesting but it's still
a mystery
who is Sinister Magnus
yeah we've had some suggestions on
Twitter some people saying oh maybe it's
a niche some people saying Hikaru some
people say oh there's something fishy
about this account as is only four days
old there we've had our detectors out
there thank you keep on investigating
some even joking that it could be hands
name
anyway we'll we'll probably get to the
bottom of who is Sinister Magnus so only
for diesel that's quite impressive then
to get to a rating of 3 000 in four days
that's a serious rating climb normally
even if you're a very strong player it
will take a lot of games but this
account it's played less than 100 games
but uh winning nearly all of them so who
beat who beats Wesley ten and a half two
and a half
I have one final suggestion this is mine
personal maybe it's Magnus age 10. oh
that's true it did do a very convincing
wrong of quite a few players
caught David caught me he got no didn't
get Simon in but in the Oslo Esports cup
we challenge all the players and
only Liam One yeah there was only one
player who beat him yeah that's true
yeah but uh yeah the mystery continues I
want to know now I want to know but uh
either way yeah Wesley was impressed by
the play of that account and clearly
it's helping his game to Spa against
strong player no matter who it is and we
also have to address the fact that
Magnus playing until 3am that's not
something that you should try at home
kids don't get into that routine trust
me it's a hard habit to kick but uh it
works for him
starting the day at 12 o'clock in San
Francisco so not getting too many hours
of sleep Magnus Carlsen
Wesley in an interview yesterday he said
he got 11 hours sleep every night was he
joking was that who can sleep for 11
hours I'm sorry I'm jealous yeah I could
but you know usually you don't have the
time for that
Lots in the way a lot
life of a chess player
all right we have a big result you guys
doing situation has actually won game
three to take it to a game four against
Liam he still has to win game four to
take it to tie breaks but hopes for Mom
there who started the Day in Israel
playing in what is it called the world
team championship yep that's right and
he started that very well he won two
games out of two wow including against
Hans Neiman so Mama jarov He's played a
lot of Chess today can he maintain the
energy for game four against Liam and
this one is kind of spicing up on the
board white here has started pushing
that a pawn it's only three squares away
from promotion blacks Rook sooner rather
than later has to slide back behind that
white a pawn you might even have to do
it now if it steps one square closer it
might have a clear run through I was
gonna say timing is off the essence you
got to know now I mean there's no Dilly
dallying here with Knight takes Pawn or
anything like that you've got to put
your Rook over to the A2 Square because
otherwise as you mentioned David The
Rook will come to C8 give a check and
then the pawn will simply walk its way
over to the A8 square and yeah a Duda
he's a strong player for a good reason
and he understands what needs to be done
but the problem is is that Magnus now is
winning a whole lot of Pawns and Duda
can win upon himself for example it's
two bones versus two right now should be
a draw but if Duda gives a check the
downside here is that White's King might
just be able to step forward and for
example if the Central Pawn disappears
suddenly the king will go on a March and
the white king will be headed towards
this Pawn to start helping it advance
and who's better here who's got the
advantage
it's really hard to say and that's why
dude is shaking his head he has lost
control you called it Ivanka a few moves
ago rather than a calm winning advantage
or at least a pawn Advantage where he
can slowly kind of improve slowly build
up he's got a position where it's a race
and he's going for this I'm expecting
Magnus to advance his King into the open
allowing and just discovered check here
but just banking everything on this porn
promoting later he could also just leave
it he could just step across one square
and if Knight takes Pawn now he could
maybe try and reactivate the white Rook
but now you are contending against two
connected past pawns it feels like black
is the only one who could win
so uh what will Magnus play he does
advance with his King maybe Black's best
bet is to play its safety of anchor and
I was gonna say not to take the pawn
and I mean I was I was wondering about
this Rick ending and Duda does do this
so we are going to see Magnus now put
his defensive skills to the test because
Judah is now going to win the B Pawn and
it will be two pawns versus one and I
don't think I've ever seen this
configuration before but it doesn't look
like the easiest of Recon Pawn endings
to hold yeah I've seen this
configuration many times including
recently an Armageddon game between uh
Annie or playoff game at least between
Anish giri and nihal sarin at the global
Chess Championship there it was colors
reversed and their Black's pawns were
slightly further forward but Nihao sarin
did beat Anish giri with two pawns
against one so this should be a draw
this position objectively if you study
end game manuals it will say definite
draw but black has two connected pawns
so there's always hope and White's Pawn
is out on a limb it doesn't stop the
black G Pawn so Magnus can he hold wow
it's not going to be easy despite the
fact that computers will tell you this
one is a draw and he has much more time
on the clock we have another big big
comeback here in game three's Arjun
aragaisy has tied the match against
part so that means they will be tied
heading into game four if there is a
winner in game four that player will win
the match if it is a draw then they will
decide the match in tie breaks
and young Christoph Duda is fighting for
that same comeback what do you guys
think is the most likely right now
if you're playing anyone other than
Magnus I would say you have very good
winning chances in PR in a practical
game but magnus's the end game expert
Magnus has held so many tough positions
like this before what do you think
Ivanka I also think it's going to be a
draw and for sure Magnus will have been
watching that game between uh Anish Gary
and their house siren so he would have
mastered up or at least brushed up on
the techniques on how to draw I wasn't
watching I'm afraid so I don't know so
I'm going to start learning and I've got
my table base here and it's telling me
that uh well as long as white just moves
The Rook it can be along the seventh can
actually be anywhere along the A-line it
can basically move anywhere it's going
to be a draw as long as you don't
blunder White's e-pawn it should be a
draw he Retreats just cutting off the
black king the black king can no longer
advance and Duda looks frustrated with
himself white also has maybe a semi
threat at some point in the near future
of pushing the e-pawn forward if white
can trade off one set of Pawns it's a
guaranteed draw one Pawn alone for black
will not do it so black somehow needs to
surround the white Pawn capture it and
it does look impossible and do the
shaking his head meanwhile I have to say
congratulations to Eric icy for that win
he won in 18 moves against Prague a
miniature as we call it a really
beautiful finish as well it was about to
end in Checkmate when Prague resigned
also Eric icy started the game with one
Knight C3 which I don't think I've ever
seen on the tour last season this season
but there is a chessboard course out by
Lawrence Trent upon that move so Eric
icy getting inspired surprising his
opponent on move one and there's a lot
to be said for surprise effect at the
top level all right we need to take a
look at that and analyze that after this
game yeah we will show the Finish wow we
can meanwhile yeah dude going through
the motions here stepping one square
forward with the pawn
do you think Ivanka is going to just try
forever is he going to try and grind
this one out for a hundred moves
it's gonna take a long time to make
progress yeah that's my man he's good
he's gonna try every single Avenue why
not because Magnus for sure would do it
against him so why not do it when the
roles are reversed and notice what
Magnus has done as soon as the black
king started coming down the board
trying to break free Magnus goes behind
with a check forcing the black king to
run again backwards for shelter and now
Magnus will most likely swing back where
he came from with his rook and he's
going to say to do the your king can't
come forward your Rook alone can't do
the job
do I have an interesting uh thing
actually The Rook must stay on the
eighth row
goes for some reason if it got anywhere
along the H line it's a loss okay so
there was a room for error there for
Magnus but he did of course keep his
Rook along the eighth rank I think he's
found the perfect defensive formation
why break it why try something new but
yeah we're treating The Rook passively
on the H file I think that's just a good
lesson for everyone don't put your Rook
passive here White's Rook is active
because it's supporting its Pawn it's
maybe hinting at the pawn Advance it's
nearer the black king I can give some
nasty checks and it also just dawned on
me that keeping the Rook on the eight
line actually prevents the black king
from mobilizing itself so if the Rook
did go on the H line then the king could
just snake its way towards the center we
can show this actually very instructive
so uh a couple a couple of moves ago
Magnus brought his Rook to the eighth
rank now this is the idea the black king
steps out trying to break free trying to
kind of come around the long way but
Magnus says no you have to retreat check
you have to go back Magnus brings his
Rook away uh this way but if he had
retreated as you say Ivanka suddenly the
black king will get into the action not
the way it wanted to but maybe a more
effective way it's going to come round
from the front and go after the white
Pawn so you have to stop Black's King
activating
and that's what he did you're completely
right there and again anytime the black
king pokes its head out the white Rook
will slow behind and say nope you have
to retreat
and this unfortunately is just a very
poor piece for black
nothing to be done about it even if
black weights now with the Rook white
can wait with his King I guess just
Shuffle it across it's important
actually to shuffle across probably to
the H4 Square again just to lock out the
black king yeah stop the black king from
advancing and nothing to be done I don't
think white should ever get Hasty and
push his Pawn forward for example
because now black would reject that
trade and the black Rook will slide
behind dealing with white spawn and it's
more important that these two have
broken free and they are connected still
so that's what Duda needs to do he needs
to keep his pawns protected protecting
each other at least and
he can give all the tracks he wants but
Magnus will just retreat you could step
forward here maybe but you don't want to
get involved in any tactics there would
be ideas of uh yeah he Retreats because
there would be ideas for example of Rook
takes rook and this is a really nice
tactic a little check and a double
attack any King and Paul name game is
winning for black Black's King comes
around this side uh to Shepard its Pawn
forward yeah so you don't want to
Checkmate yourself essentially Magnus of
course doesn't trap his King he Retreats
now his King has some breathing space
still a draw an instructive point there
David and uh it is still a draw but it's
quite interesting how Magnus will handle
the position once the black king steps
forward
I think that's the only winning try for
Duda at least now the white King's been
pushed back slightly the black king can
try and
come around but okay he starts pushing
pawns the one downside to this one is
that the black pawns are no longer
connected so there's some risk involved
but more reward if Black's King gets one
more move slide down to the square that
was previously occupied by this Pawn
maybe some chances
still be a draw though Magnus Waits now
if the black king poked his head out to
the sixth rank Magnus was ready to give
a check
but Duda looking pretty confident he's
his King is Coming
suddenly I would be worried if I were
Magnus
if I'm into the shoes I feel like I've
made progress
it certainly looks that way but uh
Magnus does have the drawing technique
you know which is simply to keep his
work active keep an eye on the F7 pawn
and everything should be okay but like
you say David I would feel be feeling
nervous yeah and this is where Magnus
he's been playing so quickly he's still
got six and a half minutes
um this is where Magnus is a class Above
the Rest if the colors were reversed I
would Bank on Magnus actually pulling
through and maybe even squeezing out a
win but often the top players in the
world they can't do that against Magnus
they can't do it vice versa when they
are the ones with extra pawns he's so
good at knuckling down and holding on
surviving
that's a skill in itself that's why he's
a universal player not just when he's on
the front foot Magnus but also when he's
holding these difficult difficult end
games
meanwhile just trying to find a way to
round up White's Pawn
there we go he goes after it but White's
Rook is most likely going back where it
came from
to defend okay it Retreats along the
fifth rank also very sensible
was one of the two ways to draw yeah you
have to defend your pawn and I'm
wondering now what's going to happen
once the king steps up and now it's just
important that The Rook stays on the
fifth row but okay Duda goes around with
the King
yeah the black king is coming oh hang on
a second here
suddenly I can see the margin for error
has suddenly increased because there's
only one way how to draw this white has
to step for step to the side with the
King and attack The Rook everything else
will lose wow so maybe we have to show
this and their stockfish does confirm
under the player's cameras white has to
shuffle his King across to F3 towards
that black Rook if Magnus Waits it he
waits one move too long if you step
across with the Rook for example the
second best move then Black's King comes
and now there's no way to stop the king
stepping forward and most likely this
Pawn is doomed two pieces will surround
it and win it this is why you have to
seize the moment now I think Magnus
should get there by process of
elimination but you have to seize the
moment now to hit this black Rook if the
black Rook moves away keeping an eye he
does find it Magnus if the black moves
away keeping an eye on this point white
king can once again get active
counter-attacking and therefore Duda had
to give a check but now Magnus his Pawn
is no longer Under Fire the Black Brook
has been kicked away and if the black
king comes now white can for example cut
off its Advance along the sixth rank
I think this is what he'll go for yeah
yeah okay in fact that is the only way
to draw David again the only move it's
very logical here however you cannot let
Black's King near your pawn and Magnus
of course he finds it but credit to Duda
he's narrowing the path again if you
keep giving your opponent these must
find moves these kind of only move
situations then eventually they might
crack and Duda his idea is to maybe
start advancing this Pawn now uh Magnus
meanwhile activating the white king
so no checks in this position for
example because White's King gets really
active and goes for the black pawn what
we'll do to try he just waits he
Retreats his rook and will most likely
see Magnus weight as well Magnus could
wait with his own Rook I think the whole
idea here is as soon as the pawn starts
running now we go back or maybe we can
go forward but I would just want to
retreat and come back and try to win it
now this Pawn is separated from the rest
of his army yeah and basically the key
is that once the king is protecting the
white Pawn then the black sorry the
white Rook is able to move to any Square
yeah now the white Rook is free you can
even come back immediately you can even
step forward
yeah this is actually difficult for
black suddenly because the king can
never really step forward without
getting checked away again so maybe this
is uh even safer for Magnus just going
already behind this black pawn
it's like a safe way to draw or he could
just wait maintain the defensive
formation it looks far from being broken
this this kind of uh cut along the sixth
rank if you just wait that's King can
never Advance there's only one really
really bad move okay so there's some
obviously bad moves to blunder Rooks but
there's one which kind of Could Happen
which is if the Rook moved to D6 now
that would be a bad move because it does
allow the F Pawn to suddenly March
forward and white cannot play on passant
because the Rook would fall yeah so you
don't want to put your Rook on a
vulnerable Square that's a very nice
tactic there your Banker so it's never
too late to blunder in an end game but
Magnus ticking down to around four
minutes I'm expecting him to wait
somewhere along the sixth rank a safe
Square along the sixth Rank and it's
still within the drawing realms
do that under 20 seconds
the good thing for him is he can play
for another 50 moves getting a bunch of
time on the clock
but against someone like Magnus he's
unlikely to work
certain players certain temperaments
will crack I often play against very
impatient players very attacking players
and here is their worst nightmare to sit
slowly and defend but yeah Magnus it's
I'm running out of compliments for him
he's just so good at these situations to
be fair though this is anyone's
nightmare
no one likes to play these kind of
positions when you are just groveling
for the draw and uh did uh he doesn't
have much time on the clock but he has
plenty of moves at his disposal and
Magnus doing the right thing you know
he's taking his time he's working out
the right plan and he's just making sure
that there's no pitfalls and he's
navigated the complications and the path
to a draw superbly I mean it's been
faultless play
yeah he's defended extremely well so far
but he still has to defend for a while
more and under three minutes Duda looks
very focused it looks like dude is kind
of planning plotting an idea a way to
try and out Fox the world number one
but yeah it's not looking easy as long
as white leaves his Rook on a sensible
Square I don't think the king needs to
move maybe White's King could move here
as well but why just uh the white king
looks beautiful where it is in the
center
yeah no need but basically most moves
draw
unless you make a howler sorry Dave it's
my middle name my nickname yeah it's not
that David how the hell
it's uh yeah my cousin calls himself DJ
howler is he famous
uh I think he'd like to think he is hi
James
yeah and not Grandmaster James Howell
there's another Grandmaster with my
surname but
a different James Howell and okay he
gives a check yeah
also fine also good
he's driving the black king maybe back
where I wanted to go anyway the black
king couldn't have stepped down to the
sixth Grant remember as we
would have seen a check well I was just
wondering this Magnus has something
Concrete in mind and this move forces
the draw wow so very clever it's a
Magnus that's why he invested a few
minutes otherwise he would have just
waited otherwise he would have just
maintained his defensive setup so he's
giving up a second Pawn again I wouldn't
advise this normally but he's so good at
calculation that he's probably worked
out if black takes this white porn now
white king will step up one square here
we go and it's impossible for impossible
for Black's Rook to defend both pawns
the problem is Black's King is
completely cut off on the seventh rank
hence due to retreating to try and break
the bind but now White's Rook is going
for that e-pawn
I was just accuracy Central David I mean
Magnus he just knows what he's doing and
Duda coming with his King but you can
okay only one move and of course Magnus
finds the way to capture you had to
capture that Paul with the rook and now
it's totally drawn look at the black
king it's completely cut off on the
sixth row and uh Duda just putting his
Rook on F1 Magnus moves it not a problem
and usually this type of end game is
very difficult for white to hold because
the white king is also cut off from
moving towards the black pawn if you
look at Black's Rook it's doing a great
job on the f-line keeping that white
white king far away but it's more about
the black king if Black's King was
anywhere other than the seventh rank if
it was on H5 if it was nearer its pawn
it would be a win for black but the
black king is just too far away Black's
Pawn as soon as it starts to run will
just drop off and I think that we'll see
the players agree a draw soon Magnus
done a great job cut off the opponent's
king that's the key in these Brooklyn
games yeah
so impressed by the way he played it and
the way that he just took that time out
and then found the forcing continuation
just to secure that draw and it all
comes about because he knows his stuff
yeah hard work like know your I was
gonna swear though don't do that you'll
be your stuff yes and here we go the
black porn does try to advance there was
nothing else for black to try but here
white is just going to give a check and
the black king if it goes to the wrong
square a check would have picked up that
black pawn instead Magnus is happy to
retreat he's driven the black king the
whole way back and now that black pawn
is doomed it's too far away from the
rest of its Army you can defend that
black porn with your Rook but then the
white king is free to move across
and Win It
yeah we'll see you draw any moment now
dude he tried to press but he couldn't
quite break magnus's defenses
and okay eruption does at least protect
its Pawn but white king is just
retreating coming back we'll end this
game with King versus King once the
black pawn drops off and there we go we
have a result
there it is it is a drool that means we
will see a game four between Magnus and
young Kristoff but it's gonna be a must
win for Duda to take it to Tiger